and 3.
up next on american history tv from a
conference titled the national security
state and jfk historians authors and
former congressmen and presidential
candidate ron paul
explore the consequences of what they
call america's security state since the
end of world war ii
topics include the military-industrial
complex president kennedy's relationship
with mary meyer wife of cia agent court
meyer and a theory linking cia spymaster
james angleton to lee harvey oswald and
jfk's assassination
former republican congressman ron paul
shares his thoughts on national security
and secrecy in the government now this
three-hour session was part of a
conference hosted by the future of
freedom foundation
all right here we go
michael swanson is the founder and
editor of the financial website wall
streetwindow.com where he writes about
the financial markets
before founding that site he co-managed
a hedge fund from 2003 to 2006.
swanson has a master's degree in
american history from the university of
virginia and has written works of 20th
century american history including
danville virginia and the coming to the
modern south
and one of the greatest books you'll
ever read the war state the cold war
origins of the military-industrial
complex and the power elite he is
currently working on a book covering the
beginning of u.s involvement in the
vietnam war from 1945 to 1963.
and i'll tell you just a little personal
anecdote you know we get a lot of books
at the future freedom foundation that
people send us to look at and review and
so forth and so i when i got the war
state from mike swanson i didn't know
who he was and and uh so i thought well
just another one of those books and i
start to stumb through it and i was just
stunned and i started really looking
through it and i take it home that night
and i was just overwhelmed with what the
power of this book and so i contacted
him and we later met at a conference in
pennsylvania on the jfk assassination
and we've been become good friends and i
can't
recommend this book too highly and in
fact he donated uh several copies so as
most of you have packed this book in
your packets and that's compliments of
mike swanson
mike the title of mike's
mike's talk is what is the purpose of
the national security state michael
swanson
[Applause]
well thanks for that kind introduction
jacob and it's a great day to be here
for everybody and uh we all have read
many of the same books and studied each
other's books and works and even talked
on the internet at times on facebook or
watched each other's
youtube shows for that matter um
i was thinking about that
uh walks with some celeb and it's real
relevant
for this topic
because in that interview they talked
about
the national security state and the
decisions to intervene in other
countries and why the people who make
these decisions
never seem to disappear or get fired or
anything and teleps
uh answer in this interview is because
they have no skin in the game
and
um
that's that's one answer um i'm going to
try to provide an additional answer to
it um
but
that's not to say i disagree with
everything taleb says he's someone i
actually
have been influenced a lot by but a lot
of studying a topic like this i think is
about asking the right questions
and going from deeper questions as time
goes on
so
the question that's kind of you when i
wrote the book you you have in your
hands i was focusing on the idea that
the united states had become an empire
basically after world war ii
and
if we flip to this statement right here
uh this is david petraeus february the
first of the armed services committee
essentially
he's not saying the word empire but he's
sort of
stating that
we have a international order that we
seek to maintain
and
um if we stop doing so he states it will
collapse and
and obviously there will be you know he
implies bad consequences to that
now
so that's his answer and what i want to
do is go through in this presentation
one of the things i'm going to do is
show
what
people such as petraeus in the past has
said the purposes of the national
security state is but the question
that's actually
kind of gripped me over the past couple
of years is how does this thing actually
work
uh how are the decisions in it actually
made and i don't think it's simply
people don't you know they can make
mistakes and they're not punished
but there is a repeating pattern of the
type of decisions that seem to
result in the last presentation you
heard with doug horn he spoke about
operation northwoods and you hear
something like that
and other you know you can think of
other
events that we don't know all the
circumstances of or or events that we do
um and you know wonder what what the
heck is going on what are these people
thinking
and
i'm going to try to give them their
argument uh
in this presentation
and
one of the things uh would you research
stuff
you'll dig something up and you'll say
what in the world is this
and
this has a name to it it's just like
this is like out of doctor strange club
or something so there's something called
project control it was a study done by
the air force in the time period
1953-1954 and i'm going to use this as a
case study and come back to it at the
end of the presentation
but
what
this was was that the u.s air war
college
there was a colonel raymond sleeper who
was taking classes getting his doctorate
he did a dissertation on air power and
how to win the next war that the air
force might fight
and he
looked back at world war ii world war
one and so forth and he wanted to make
the next war one that the air force
would win for sure
and he came up with this idea of project
control and what it was
was
to
go to the soviet union and at the time
they had a huge disadvantage
in nuclear weapons in regards to the
united states they didn't have any
nuclear missiles that could reach the
continental us
they only had a handful of bombers that
would have had to refuel to make it back
uh it's
dubious if they would have been able to
drop anything so we had a huge advantage
of in the 50s and to continue to the mid
60s really and
his plan was okay
we'll go to the soviets we want them to
surrender this is a plan to win so we
will do
intensive overflights over the soviet
union at first to kind of intimidate
them and scare them and then we'll drop
a couple bombs and then we'll issue them
an ultimatum and tell them you better
surrender now and then if they don't
we'll stop dropping atomic bombs until
they do sort of
uh heightened up version of what
happened uh to the japanese after world
war ii now
what was interesting about this study
is um
it went up to
this is guy just doing a dissertation
and it goes up to the top levels of the
air force and they hear about it and
they get all excited
and they say oh we've got this is not
just a dissertation we're going to
devote
huge resources at the u.s air war
college to make this a workable plan
they even got people in the cia to work
on it people from outside the air force
uh even civilians about a hundred people
i spent a year working on it and
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
told them he liked the idea
and he briefed uh alan dulles john
foster dulles the secretary of defense
um wilson
and
it was mentioned
in um in two national security council
meetings you can read them the foreign
relations united states series they
don't use the word project control in
the minutes
but in
these the two ladder meetings i have
listed right there
um it's discussed should we
what should we do the whole the two
topics are what should we do about the
soviet union
um at this point in time going forward
it's president eisenhower with his top
national security advisors
and uh joint chiefs of staff and so
forth the chairman and they debate
should we just bomb them should we
do a first strike
in the guise of this project control
and
interesting enough john foster dulles
argues no and i find
that interesting because
you know in the in that public
imagination he's the one associated with
rollback uh nuclear retaliation
and so forth and he says no no this is a
bad idea and his reasoning is that
he says this would be strategically
pointless that we wouldn't really win
anything out of this and then he talks
about eastern europe and he says we
really don't even need to roll back in
eastern europe
you know which is amazing because this
is the guy that you know in public is
saying this all the time and his
argument is that well if eastern europe
we don't if we roll them back we're not
really going to get anything because the
soviets are still going to be there and
in five eight years they'll have nuclear
weapons and so there's really nothing to
gain we'll just keep western europe so
there was a point of this is over
a month period inside the air force and
i'm not saying the entire pentagon was
on board of this or the entire joint
chiefs of staff but inside the defense
department in the air force there was
you know a move to get a program like
this trickled up
and it got you know briefed to the
people the highest levels and it gets
rejected
in eisenhower i think at that
this nothing like this ever comes up
again as far as i know from looking at
these documents now all this sounds
wacko i mean really
i mean it's so crazy john foster dollars
rejected it
so
but um
in reality you know i i want what i want
to what i'm trying to
figure out and i'm going to
show you my answers here is how to
reason how do arguments like this
make sense to these people how how does
something like operation northwoods
or
this
project control
you know make sense to people in the
national security state or at least some
of them um now again that's the uh
the book i wrote and i just want to
emphasize that
to go back to the david petraeus
statement
you know what i touched about in the
book is
really the creation
of the american national security state
after world war ii up to the end of the
kennedy presidency and it didn't exist
uh before world war ii
um and it now we take it for granted you
know it's it's an everyday part of our
lives it's
you know the question on tv
is
going to be soon should donald trump our
president send troops to afghanistan
so it's always you know
about where should we intervene next
basically and if you go back though to
the petraeus statement
if you just look at the simple logic of
it he seems to suggest that
if we don't
maintain order
uh throughout the world then everything
will collapse so
that would imply that intervention
or some sort of aggressive foreign
policy
is uh necessary
and i think that's the real purpose of
the national security state now there's
other purposes
to defend us
let's say against china
i don't know what the odds of them
attacking us tomorrow are or defending
us against terrorism which has got to
slightly higher odds but on an
individual basis it's not very likely
and then you have to wonder what are the
costs of intervention
is this just
you know
does the interventions themselves create
the terrorism that
you know we
hear about now almost every week
somewhere in the world
um so i would assert that
fighting terrorists or stopping
terrorists
is an objective of the national security
state but
it's not the primary objective the
primary objective being
basically
to maintain uh its view of international
order or i would say world order um
but i think that you know
a result of that is you end up creating
essentially endless wars
uh the funny thing though
is you people you study these topics and
if you look at something like cia regime
changes
in the 1950s in guatemala and central
america and iran and elsewhere
you can conclude well what's the purpose
of nations if you ask yourself what's
the purpose of national security state
if you look at those operations you
might say well it's to protect a united
fruit companies to protect
the oil interests in iran it's maybe to
protect the clients of the dulles
brothers who are running the ca at the
time
and if you go to the vietnam war and you
read about laos and cambodia
you can find books about drug smuggling
of heroin out of those countries there's
drugs smuggling
in the united states during the
nicaraguan war
the contra
covert operations and you might think
well it's all about drug smuggling
people are making money from drugs
and
maybe there's a whole deep state
involved in doing that
or is it about just simply
the purpose really about the defense
industry and making profits for general
dynamics and
raytheon that are just up the road here
and getting them to give campaign
contributions to
congressmen to give them more contracts
and so forth you know these are i think
side effects of
different history historical periods of
if you call them war operations covert
operations national security state
operations but i don't that
there's no i can't find any evidence
though that that any of those things
motivates
the people i'm looking at
primarily in the pentagon
that are making decisions or making
proposals that i don't think they care
those people about any of those things
and i think those are really the people
at the top of the national security
state the most important
uh people running
but it's
become
so much a part of our life
if you look at this conference
that right now
we're in the fairfax virginia area
and uh
it's it's kind of ironic because the cia
headquarters is in fairfax county the
national care counter terrorism center
is in fairfax county
fort belvoir is in fairfax county which
is the headquarters for army
intelligence which is actually larger
than the central intelligence operation
now
in the ca in the history this county is
tied up
with the national security state and the
american economy in 1950 there were a
hundred thousand people living in this
county
in 1955
65 000 people employed here 31 000 of
them work for the federal government
000 for the central intelligence agency
in the 1950s there was a complete boom
in the defense industry
and really the national security state
tied in
with an arms race
which is really non-existent
with the soviet union which i'll talk
about in a minute but during that boom
the population of this county tripled
and then in the 1960s under the vietnam
war it doubled again
so the health of this county or the
economy of it's directly tied into
the national security state
in
interventions overseas now the funny
thing about that is
if you look at
average income per person in the united
states rank it by counties this county
is number two
in the entire country
number one is loudoun county which is a
neighboring county to this one
i guess that's where all the bosses work
at
but for the rest of the country there
are in the world for that matter there's
cost to all this um
i would say the history that we're
studying or most of us in here are very
interested in regards to the kennedy era
is a direct consequence of the rise of
the national security state and i would
say to just put it real simple
political instability in the 1960s and
70s whether you
want to look at political assassinations
or simple
riots in the streets anti-war marches
whatever you want to look at you know
it's political instability and then the
debts during that war piled up
in 1967
they got to be so large that
uh
there was a crisis
1967 was
really a crisis year for the national
security state that i don't really
hasn't been studied in that way
um
hopefully someone will
pick up that project but what happened
was uh it became clear in the summer
1967 that they weren't
winning the vietnam war and at the same
time riots in the ghettos across america
were breaking out
and at the same time gold was running it
was fleeing the bolts of the united
states and flowing into europe
and um
there's a
a quote where the head of army
intelligence is writing to a member of
the joint chiefs of staff and saying the
american empire's in crisis because of
these things these three things i just
listed so
the people running this knew you know
this was kind of cracking up and
i you know
and then we had watergate uh the church
committee hearings the house select
committee of assassinations attempts to
reform
um some successful probably that some
not but they were there
but today you know then we had the
reagan era
and uh he ran for president on making
america great again
and
turning the page on
these times of troubles
and
for much of the country i think he did
succeeded that the economy boom the
stock market boom and so forth but now
we here we are today
after 9 11 after more
endless wars uh
seeming return
to some strange fashion of political
instability where we have
uh the media on tv
uh
comparing donald trump to richard nixon
and and and so forth and uh
just crazy times and everyone i think no
matter what side of the political
spectrum you are on uh everyone feels
like that
uh on on all sides of it
but probably nobody
if i could recommend one book
um about this topic i'd recommend
david stockman's book
the great deal of day formation on the
topic of the cost of all this
um
now i'll go return
to statements of some of these national
security officials on the purposes of
the national security state this is from
the pentagon papers uh written in 1967
again that year of crisis
and um
robert mcnamara commissioned them to go
and look what are the reasons we got in
this war
uh and
he came back uh he got this answer back
from the guy that was in charge of the
paper 70 percent
of the reason was to simply avoid defeat
and only not to help a friend that
wasn't on the list 10 to help south
vietnamese determination in other words
to help that government survive 20 to
keep south vietnam
out of the hands of china well
what the statement shows is that to
to me is that the reasons for continuing
the war were simply to continue the war
and
but yeah that might that i'm not
what but why what why is it necessary to
simply continue this
and
um
i would say
skipping ahead a little bit but i would
say that they have a fear and i'll get
to show you the quotes on that in a
second but there's a fear that if any if
any element of national security state
were to pull back from from a war
or a confrontation
or even pull bases back
that that's a sign of
what they call provocative weakness
and that's a statement you can find in
national security speeches and documents
i've got a quote i'll show you in a
second of donald rumsfeld saying this at
his retirement speech
and with john f kennedy
that's essentially what he was doing he
was pulling back
from confrontation with the soviet union
in the last year of his life and his
famous uh peace speech
and so forth and from the vietnam war
and all
even trying to limit the defense budget
but he explicitly
in his peace speech said we don't want a
pax americana
which is a complete
repudiation of
basically saying we're going to maintain
order around the world through our the
use of
nuclear power in our weapons
uh but
to think about the vietnam war though uh
for kennedy himself
he sent advisors there in 1961 and it
was primarily
in his you know his goal
you could describe it as a
nation-building project to help
the south vietnamese defeat an
insurgency and develop their nation he
was skeptical of whether it would
succeed but that was the mission he sent
people to do and the idea was you're
going to have about 15 000 advisers over
there and these are trainers they're
going to stay by the end of his term
he's
put in writing they're staying till 1965
and that's going to be their mission and
and but for the joint chiefs of staff
who
really pushed kennedy
to intervene in vietnam in the first
place they didn't see
vietnam
as a nation-building project at all
they saw it as primarily competition
with china
that china was
the
dominant power
on in land on in asia and they were
going to grow an influence in the
southeast asia in their view
and the united and it was going to be
between the us and china who is going to
be the big
uh bad player in southeast asia and they
were determined it would be us
and this shows up first this type of
thinking
actually in in
this august 1954 meeting of dwight
eisenhower uh that was there's a
discussion about china after dien bin fu
fell which was the french
effort there uh and they're talking what
do we do now china in in vietnam and the
same proposals came up the question one
question was well should we just bomb
them you know
he said they said no we're not we're not
going to do the dice ours no we're not
going to do that
and they basically settled on the idea
we will give them threats we will tell
them if they go into
another country we will bomb them
but we we will develop
and defend south vietnam and southeast
asia
so that was the initial genesis of
u.s direct involvement in south vietnam
and eisenhower sends a very small
handful of people over there the cia of
course
helps
diem who's the south vietnamese premier
get a foothold in power and maintain it
and the whole effort ends up collapsing
by the end of kennedy's error at least
dm's rule and it becomes a militarized
operation completely by the time lyndon
johnson is in there but the point is
that china was the big the big thing and
in their view this the joint chiefs of
staff you wasn't we're going to go
develop this country it was okay who's
going to rule the world really
in this part of the world the u.s or
china and vietnam that's what vietnam
was about
for them
in fact
robert mcnamara
himself
wrote a letter to
lbj basically saying this is the reason
we got involved here in the first place
this china issue and his national
security advisor mcgeorge bundy
in early 1965 wrote a famous memo
telling lbj he needed to intervene in
south vietnam more aggressively and bomb
and he had china also as the main reason
and he
said in this memo that he didn't think
we had a better than 50 chance of even
winning
but it would still be worth doing to
show china how serious we were
about using military force
so if we look at really the founding
document i think of the cold war
um it's nsc 68 written in 1950
um
it was
a lobby effort really by the secretary
of defense and truman or secretary of
state and truman was uneasy about even
signing it
because what they were aiming to do and
what they did
with this document was justify the huge
arms race of the 1950s
and
that line in the document though
at the end shows me that it's more than
about
cold war communism it's again about
maintaining order
around the world
and
in this document they weren't looking to
uh they were looking to contain the
soviet union and china and communism not
looking to
do first strikes or
even roll back but this key line though
justified
treating every other country in the in
the so-called third world any neutral
country
as
a enemy if they're not an ally so they
didn't allow neutrality
and that kind of justified the cia to
uh
oh
is it working
i'm not sure is the battery or oh should
i just talk loud or
okay i'll just do that
so
you never know
well
um
to give you an an exam to come to go
back till today i'll jump now i'll jump
to uh
okay thank you
thanks
to go
to go back and relate this to today uh
because you know the national security
state didn't go away but it's still here
with us um a buzzword used
a buzzword a buzzword uh used today is
full spectrum dominance
you see that in pentagon papers there is
a pentagon paper written after 9 11
which was a document similar to nfc 68
like a strategic overview this is what
we're doing and
it's called i think vision 2020 and it
has it was the first document to use
this this line full spectrum dominance
in it and that's this is the definition
of that according to the defense
department of defense and the dictionary
uh found just an entry couple of just a
couple weeks ago but to make a long
story short what they said is they want
total control basically
of any potential battlefield
on the planet including your cell phone
uh for that for that matter and um the
computer
so and now we have information wars if
there's anything going to come out of
of the the controversy of russia and
trump and what did trump do
uh one side effect of of this is going
to be
an intensive focused
uh by the pentagon on information wars
which really hasn't been there at all i
was watching a hearing
uh about the cia report that came out
whether the cia i mean whether russia
intervened in the in the
election or not and the whole hearing
was mostly about
we need more money to put
to start doing this ourselves
and then build a base of nato to do this
in central europe so that that was
really an interesting thing now
another key phrase which i used earlier
is provocative weakness
which really i think you know applies to
the kennedy era and what some members of
the joint chiefs of staff had seen as a
problem with kennedy and that's that any
weakness could be interpreted as
provocative by any potential enemy and
therefore
risks us
our own security
so that's a
that's a mindset that can justify a lot
of things you know
but what
they really meant if you go to the
kennedy era
uh
is that
even though the u.s had this huge
advantage at the time
in nuclear arsenal compared to the
soviets and the chinese actually had
nothing while kennedy was president um
they worried that if the soviets didn't
believe we would use them then the
weapons actually uh
were fairly meaningless in a certain
sense that's probably true
but
what's the answer to that it's just the
way the world is what are you going to
do
just
use these weapons
and the problem is
if you take these type of
thinking to their logical inclusion
you're going to get dangerous
situations
in crises such as the cuban missile
crisis the demands among the joint
chiefs of staff
for kennedy to bomb cuba during the
cuban missile crisis
proposals such as the operation
northwoods reflects a desire to to have
a more aggressive posture take advantage
of opportunities when you can get them
and
during the cuban missile crisis some
members of the joint chiefs of staff
actually saw
kennedy's blockade
or hesitation to make a decision in
their view as provocative weakness and
they rate they actually wrote memos to
robert mcnamara lecturing him uh not the
flinch if war
uh turned out to be necessary saying
that they could even win
and here's one such
memo i'm not going to read the whole
thing but the ending sums it up this is
no time to run scared so
you know this is during the depths of
the cuban missile crisis
and a fascinating moment in the cuban
missile crisis
um
which i think provides light on all this
well what's because what i'm really
trying to do is get into what are the
motivations of these of the joint chiefs
of staff
and
you know
there's a fame the famous confrontation
is when kennedy is meeting the joint
chiefs of staff in person he gets into
an argument of curtis lemay uh doug horn
mentioned that
at the end of his talk
but the next day after that meeting
there is a very fascinating
final meeting
not the end of the crisis but a decision
meeting in which kennedy and
the members of the group talking about
the cuban missile crisis with them make
the final decision on whether to do a
blockade or whether to do an airstrike
they've been arguing about this and now
they have a final argument
and
unfortunately this is one meeting we
don't have tapes of
and we don't have
word by word transcripts of the meeting
but we have notes
and the most
fascinating i mean they do decide to do
the blockade
obviously but
the mo one of the most fascinating parts
this whole discussion
uh is this line in that from the notes
where general taylor explains why they
need to bomb cuba
and he says
namely if we do not destroy the missiles
and the bombs we will have to change our
entire military way of dealing with
external threats
what does that mean
well
i
i i mean i'm not i'm not i'm not trying
to say taylor's crazy i mean i'm trying
to say i mean at some point you do kind
of have to laugh at these things because
it is like dark stuff you talk about
project control or talk about duking the
soviet union basically and then here's a
really strange line but i think done you
can understand how someone could think
or say something like this then i think
we can understand
how the net how the national security
state works or how at least how the
joint chiefs of staff works in the
pentagon and what the real purpose is
now
president eisenhower's fear
about what he called the
military-industrial complex uh in that
famous speech i got it on the cover of
my book his fear wasn't that
the next president would be
hemmed in by the national security state
so to speak or or that we're going to
have the vietnam war
or anything like that
what he primarily was scared of
was our former government actually
changing completely
or our way of life
and
as in a series of a couple national
security council meetings his final ones
he expressed what this fear was that the
spending that the military was going to
demand
was going to overwhelm
the government budget and just
completely busted
and
he thought
the result of that would be inflation
that would get out of control
and i've always thought to myself that
you know over the years that well
you know we have a giant bud a budget
deficit and maybe the everything's just
going to go broke and that'll be how the
empire our empire ends we just go broke
and i think that's seems sort of logical
but that's not what eisenhower thought
would happen
he thought what would happen was
the inflation would get out of control
and it wouldn't never end
and we would basically
me that would basically mean the end of
private enterprise as we know it
and
everything would just be consumed by
this i mean it's hard to imagine this
kind of scenario i mean i can't really
imagine it
and it obviously didn't happen
but then again it did happen because
in 1972
the
the united states went off the gold
standard
um
before we when we were on the gold
standard there is a actual limit to the
size the budgets we could make
and as i mentioned earlier around 1967
the
flow of gold started to go out of the
united states into europe because these
deficits got bigger and no one really
knew what was going to happen you can go
back to the 1970s and find books
predicting this would mean the complete
collapse of western civilization
basically the end of the gold standard
and
you know luckily nixon took us off and
and one result was there was inflation
in the 1970s not as bad as eisenhower
feared but it did happen
and then the situation seems to settle
down
eventually
with ronald reagan and paul volcker with
lots of cost
raising interest rates to stop inflation
wiped out farmers across
the whole country put lots of people out
of work so there's victims
to these economic policies that were
necessary as a result of the whole mess
of the vietnam war financially
and
basically the fears eisenhower actually
had coming to root in a way
you don't really think of unless you you
know read those notes and hear them talk
about how he's worried about government
spending
now i like to recommend one book
to read about the subject of bureaucracy
because in the end that's what the
national security state is it's a it's a
bureaucratic
institution
and that's the best way i think to
understand it
and a bureaucracy operates differently
than a private enterprise does
and that sort of links back
to
the
the nicholas tulabe
saying that he had that
these people have no skin in the game in
a way they have no financial loss at
stake
if they make a decision to
you know
send people to war
but
i think there's more to it than that
and
it's has to do with the way decisions
inside of a bureaucracy are made
which
isn't an easy thing to understand even
if you are in one
but i think that's how general taylor
can speak
about we've got to use these weapons or
bomb or else the weapons are no good and
then i have no purpose anymore basically
what are you saying what are we going to
do
so
but the the mises book doesn't
it's a short book it's it's pretty easy
to read and he's not
he's not saying all bureaucracies are
bad
uh
if i recall wright he he likes the
police force and the postal service but
if you either way if you just look at
the postal service or think of the
ponytail express
yeah that's a small bureaucracy
it's not that big
and they have a very simple defined
mission that's just deliver the mail
and
that's it and go home at night
and
take our paycheck with the national
security state they don't have a simple
mission their mission expands it expands
and expands
with two purposes
to keep the united states safe for us
safe but also
to maintain
order all over the world which i think
is their primary
mission
but i wonder
to them
that makes perfect sense
and
is completely in their mind necessary
but
i wonder if it really is
and
a way a bureaucracy works
of the size of of the pentagon
most of the decisions are made at a
lower level
by people
that are trying to
do what they think their superiors want
them to do
basically
it create proposals that they're that
they think will get passed or accepted
not make proposals that will be rejected
and they can take on
uh basically in their own mind
the objectives of the organization
in any organization
or bureaucracy such as national security
state it comes into being with a purpose
a good purpose at first
um it came into being to win world war
ii essentially
um and i think it's
by the time we're bombed at pearl harbor
i think it's hard to argue that against
that
but any bureaucratic organization this
big
over time it'll come to have its own
purposes that go beyond the original
purpose
and that's one of the key insights of
of this book here
and also this book
probably the the best i mean if you
forget about reading my book or the
other beast's book but read this one if
you're going to read one book militarism
usa
it's written by james donovan
ford by david shoop david shoop was a
commander of the marine corps under john
f kennedy who is on the joint chiefs of
staff
james donovan was one of his assistants
what this book does is essentially make
all the arguments i just made today
in a more eloquent manner and by someone
uh who
i was there you know at the highest
levels he won the medal of honor
you can't really argue with his life
experience
now
one thing he shows in that book
though
is he breaks down
how the decisions on the joint chiefs of
staff are made and they're made
the way he depicts it
on the planning staff which horn
mentioned
but the planning staff consists of four
about 400 individuals from all branches
of the service mostly colonels and they
come their whole job is to come together
and create war plans
to figure out how we're going to fight
this war that war and one thing they
have to do is incorporate every branch
of the service into the plans because
they have to please everybody that
they're working for you know they're
coming from their own organizations
and they got to divide up the budgets to
make sure everyone's got a role
and so forth so i'll go back
to that project control as a case study
of bureaucracy
so here's this fella
right to dissertation it goes up
to the highest levels of the air force
and it's kooky you know basically
nowadays we think of it as think of it
as silly uh and it was rejected by the
white house and his advice and
eisenhower's advisors but why why why
why now did this go up well i was
reading about this in air force history
of this this project
and after
the south after the french were defeated
in south vietnam the air force had a
had a problem
which i've read this for the first time
as i
it is this is amazing so when eisenhower
was president he actually
gave
the air force more money than he did the
other branches of service
and
with a new look policy but
what it said was you're going to use
these weapons as a first strike
i mean that was first strike as a as a
massive retaliation in case they do
something to us and that actually left
the air force out of plans on what to do
in the next war in vietnam or elsewhere
with atomic weapons or anything else
so how we how we're going to win a
guerilla war in south vietnam or laos or
any of these other countries what's the
role of air power and this guy's
dissertation solved that the next war
will be war not world war ii and a half
not a guerrilla war it'll be world war
three
and they loved it because of that reason
so
at the time
so thanks for uh
being here and being a part of this
conference
[Applause]
my
that didn't look good
that's not that's jenny
i'm glad you said something
because it would have been bad yeah
i'm freaking out
all right okay thank you
peter jenny has been a practicing
psychologist educator and consultant for
over 35 years
he is the author of mary's mosaic the
cia conspiracy to murder john f kennedy
mary p show meyer and their vision for
world peace
if you buy the book which i highly
recommend it is a true life murder
mystery and paige turner once you start
reading it you will not be able to put
it down be sure you buy the final
edition third edition because it is
provides a real up-to-date um recap
recapitalization of what he's talking
about in the book
it details the his many years of
investigation into washington's most
famous unsolved murder of mary meyer
the book was the general nonfiction
winner of the 2012 hollywood book
festival and received honorable mentions
in the 2012 northeast book festival and
the 2012 london book festival
hollywood producer and director oliver
stone who directed the movie jfk called
the book a fascinating story and said
that quote peter janie's unsparing
analysis moves us closer to a reckoning
a graduate of princeton where he studied
american history under martyr martin
duberman jenny earned a doctoral degree
in psychology at boston university in
1981 he currently resides by the sea in
beverly massachusetts
the title of his talk is jfk and mary
meyer relationship as redemption peter
janie
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
great well
very nice to be here i'm very taken with
what's taking place today and
the things that have been said
this is going to be a little bit of a
different talk i'm not a journalist by
trade i'm not a historian by trade
i'm a clinical psychologist
but i bring
a
a wealth of what i would call intensive
research
to
how
this story unfolded because i was
part of it
indirectly
and
as most of you who have read the book
know
i
pretty much come to the conclusion that
my own father
was part of the conspiracy
uh to murder mary meyer uh
in 1964.
i want to just begin by just saying a
couple of things about the study of
history
having
spent a lot of time reading history
books
i think i personally have come to the
conclusion that you know today we are
still on the battlefield of memory
in terms of what took place in dallas in
1963
uh and that means that history is always
going to be revisionist to one degree or
another
the judgment of history is never set
because history is ultimately a moving
dialogue even today
many historians are still fighting over
for instance the american revolution
every piece of history therefore to one
degree another
ultimately is subjective because it
comes through the mind of a particular
historian
and while historical accuracy and
objectivity must always remain
the historian's holy grail
it can only be approximated and never
really consummated
still there is much good historians can
achieve
particularly in exposing those facts
that any society tends to hide about
itself
facts about wealth and poverty tyranny
and lies and then of course
assassination and murder
the closest that we can come to
exclusive objectivity is to report
accurately
all the subjectivities in any given
situation and that requires scrupl
scrupulous honesty
in reporting the past
when we compare the government's
self-proclaimed benevolence and devotion
to democracy to its actual policies
thereby exposing the hidden ideological
pretenses that pervade our culture
therefore in terms of telling our
history we have to tell it ourselves
it's an ongoing and never-ending
struggle each generation has to gener
has to
wrestle with a history of what came
before
and then ask
whose interest does this history serve
how does it advance a legacy it serves
for instance the power of the peace
movement in the late 1960s changed the
entire national security apparatus
including the cia and the pentagon
we have to resist their military
occupation of our minds and the minds of
future generations
now there are forces in our culture
that stand for denial and i don't mean
just climate denial
or the truth
of indigenous people who have occupied
this continent long before
to conquer them but generations of
denial which have created historical
denial
our national forgetting in denial is
basically pathological from a
psychologist's point of view
because our systems our politics our
media our culture they're totally out of
balance
our collective refusal to admit that the
vietnam war for instance was wrong and
the anti-war peace movement was right is
a very important example of that
now
a really good example of what i'm
talking about
is if we look at what is taking place in
germany today and how they have
integrated the holocaust into the fabric
of their nation's history
as filmmaker michael moore pointed out
in his recent film where to invade next
every day in germany in every school
they teach their young what their
predecessors did they don't whitewash it
they don't pretend it didn't happen they
treat it as original sin a permanent
mark
on their collective german soul one for
which they must always seek redemption
make reparation and most importantly
never forget
and they can't forget because outside of
their homes on the sidewalks on the
walls of the streets are little
engravings that remind them of the
jewish families that used to live in
those houses and who were taken away and
killed
local artists have been stalled around
town
little signs that say
jews forbidden signs from the 1930s to
continue to remind today's generation in
germany that to be german
isn't just about beethoven and bach but
also about genocide and evil
what would our signs look like if we
were to honestly look back at the
assassinations that took place in the
1960s
what would our schools teach
if we wanted to truly teach our young
the whole story of what it means to be
an american
the first step
in any psychological healing to be a
better person
and in a larger sense a better country
is to stand up and honestly say who and
what we are
i am an american i live in a great
country that was born in genocide and
built on the back of slaves that's just
the truth
if there's one thing we should take from
germany it is the idea
that it is to acknowledge your dark side
come to terms with it and face it
honestly
thereby making amends for it
that way you can free yourself of the
past and evolve into something more
whole and integrated they're becoming a
better person a better nation
and
be a better fellow
citizen for the all of those on planet
earth
now
in my exploration of the cold war era
specifically with the understanding of
how the cia
operated given my father was in fact a
high-level cia official
no other
cold war historian other than elf
fletcher prouty
was the one who warned us that the
greatest casualties of the cold war had
been the truth
and the pursuit of truth
at no time in our history has the
general public been so misled so be
trade and and so deceived as it was in
the last 20th century
so therein lies the cancerous tumor upon
the soul of america the cia's inception
the entrance into the american landscape
fundamentally altered not only the
functioning of our government but our
access to the real truth of what was
actually really taking place
simply put
the cia's reign has contaminated
historical truth
and while the dismantling of america's
republic didn't begin in dallas in 1963
that day surely marked an unprecedented
acceleration of the erosion of our
democratic republic
now the cia was from its inception
virtually unaccountable to any authority
it was subject to any little if any
congressional oversight and that would
increasingly haunt
uh president howard truman and to some
extent even president eisenhower both
were troubled by the fact
that the agency had a carte blanche get
out of jail card free for anything it
attempted this was sort of came out of
the 1948 nsc meeting 10-2 i think it's
called
you forgive me i get a little parched
but remember that the late elder
american statesman george kennan
would publicly come out to deeply regret
near the end of his life the power that
had been given to the agency part of
which he signed off on
the get out of jail card free known as
public plausible
deniability was as kennon told histori
gale historian john lucas the greatest
mistake i ever made in my life and in
the mid 1970s kennen reiterated that
statement before a u.s senate
subcommittee and of course today it
continues
here is
the statement of my friend john kiriakou
who i think most of you know was
recently uh in the not too distant past
put in prison for a couple of years this
is what he says
uh as late as this past march
one of the things that most observers
don't understand is that the cia will do
anything anything to survive
all cia officers are taught to lie
they lie all the time about everything
to everybody and they justify it by
trying to convince themselves that they
are doing it in the national interest
for national security from my very first
day in the cia it was drilled into me as
it is to every other employee that quote
the primary mission is to protect the
agency that was the mantra
couple that with the cia's ability to
intercept today and take over virtually
any communications device and you have a
frankenstein monster
it's really hard to believe such an
organization would resist a president
who challenged it that goes for jfk as
well as donald trump
is it hard to believe that it would do
so surreptitiously i don't think so says
mr kiriakou
now let me turn
to
mary pincholmeir most of you
who are familiar with my book or this
story
know that
this was an exceptional human being an
incredibly beautiful woman
who had a very significant influence
not on just
jfk but also initially her husband cord
meyer
she was born in new york city in ninth
new york city in 1920 the year women got
the vote
and a family
upon which there was quite a bit of
wealth and privilege and she was
encouraged to explore and become
independent her father amos pincho was
the leader of the progressive wing of
the republican party
and he always worked toward industrial
and labor reform
he would become one of the founders
along with norman thomas and roger
baldwin of the american civil liberties
union
always outspoken amos was a champion of
causes no matter what it might have cost
him politically or socially
mary's mother the journalist ruth
pickering was also born in new york city
she was 20 years younger than amos when
she married him
she attended vasser college and columbia
university
she too came from a family of courageous
liberal thinkers
she was the kind of rare woman who dared
to define herself even back in the 1920s
resisting the prescribed roles that most
women found during that time playing she
became very active in the women's
suffrage movement and for years shared a
house with the political socialist max
eastman and his sister crystal
now let's fast forward
to february 1936.
the young and beautiful mary pinchot is
now 15 years old and already physically
stunning
and a beautiful young woman to behold
in her teen years
she
was
had at her beckon call the debutante
balls of new york city and new york
city's night life
she hung out a lot at the ritz carlton
or the waldorf astoria
mary always seemed to emerge as the
belle of the ball
her weekends were often filled with
parties at new england's most elite prep
schools places like saint paul's choate
and groton among them
now while attending the winter
festivities weekend in 1936 at choate in
wallingford connecticut
her date for that weekend was the young
and dashing william atwood
whom she had been seriously dating since
christmas atwood as we know would
eventually become president kennedy's
ambassador to the west african country
of guinea
he would also be at the heart of a
kennedy-sanctioned
secret mission in the fall of 1963
to explore the rapprochement with fidel
castro behind the backs of the pentagon
and the cia
but in the winter of 1936 atwood was the
guy with the prettiest date it showed
what bill atwood did not know that
saturday night in february of 1936 was
that jfk having already graduated from
chote had decided to return for the
winterfest festivities weekend and
attend the gala saturday evening dance
it was a black tie tales event
and we don't know excuse me
what drove
jfk back to joad at at that time that
remains a mystery i mean i mean when we
look at this situation how far could a
tomcat like the young jfk navigate the
confines of a heavily chaperoned new
england prep school dance
and what would a college boy he was
still a freshman at princeton then no
less want with a parochial school
function anyway
but he returned unaccompanied he was a
stag perhaps he thought the homecoming
was unfamiliar to territory would be
good for his self-confidence which had
lagged since he'd been forced to take a
medical leave of absence from his
studies at princeton
whatever the force that drew him
backward that evening
or forward if we look at forces at work
here it is it that's not known but
something propelled him for during that
winter festivities dance
he would encounter mary pinchot for the
very first time etching in
his being an
unforgettable moment
gracious as she was when jfk kept
cutting in on the dance floor
with atwood sporadically running
upstairs to gargle listerine because he
had a very bad sore throat
still no romantic interest on mary's
part took place at that time
there were other men who would first
cross her trajectory
atwood being one peter peter jessup
being another followed with by bob
schwartz and then finally her husband
cord meyer
but the encounter between jfk and mary
in 1936 was for the both of them a major
life event
when we look to history to help us
understand events and circumstances that
shape personal lives as well as the life
and fate of
an entire country
certain individuals seem to appear at
the most extraordinary moments when the
stakes could not be possibly higher
now in post-world war two america
with the new reality of what might
it mean to live in the nuclear age
there were two
young very promising very well
positioned men who were emerging as
potential leaders of the new era
one of the fascinating elements of this
era was that mary meyer would end up
becoming the muse to both of
them let's just here we have the
july 1947 issue of glamour magazine and
in this magazine
is a major feature article
uh it was called
10 young men who care
here we just see young men who care but
they were ranked in order of importance
and the first two which were tied for
first place were court meyer on the left
and john f kennedy
on the right
now court meyer
was
in many ways
a wounded man
just as as jfk was both in his
temperament
uh
cord was fundamentally a poet and as one
of teachers liked to say said
but when he exploded he blew like a half
gale
at his early years cord was decidedly a
pacifist
his father feared the worst for his
sensitive artistic stun son as they
prepared for world war ii and as all his
sons he had decided cord to be able to
take the pressures of war the least
quote if any of them crack up under it
he told one journalist it will be cored
so in the early 1944
on july 22nd a japanese grenade rolled
into his foxhole exploding in his face
and killing his sergeant
cordley mortally wounded contemplating
death bleeding everywhere pieces of his
teeth like half-eaten peanuts awash in
his mouth and blood
with horror cord realized he was blind
still conscious he searched with one
hand for his 45 caliber pistol to end
his misery
why had he not followed his conscience
and refute refused military service he
bemoaned as he lay there dying cursing
nation-state sever savagery and war
as we know
court lived
and two years later he would write an
award-winning short story called wave of
darkness
which he articulated that night
in that foxhole and this was his appeal
for world peace as he emerged from the
second world war
and in this short story
there's a paragraph here that i want to
read to you because it is fundamentally
poignant to a level of who court meyer
was and why
like jfk
for a while at least he really was a
believer in world peace
and what he wrote was this quote
what if he should get out of his foxhole
and explain the matter reasonably to
both sides
fellow human fellow human beings he
would begin
there are very few of us here who in
private
would kill a man for any reason
whatsoever the fact that guns have been
placed in our hands and some of us wear
one uniform and somewhere the other is
no excuse for the mass murder we are
about to commit
there are differences between us i know
but none of them worth the death of one
man
most of us
are not here by our own choice we were
taken from our peaceful lives and told
to fight for reasons we cannot
understand
surely we have more in common
than
that which temporary temporarily
separates us
fathers go back to your children who are
in need of you husbands go back to your
young wives who cry in the night and
count the anxious days farmers return to
your fields where the grain rots and the
house slides into ruin
the only certain fruit of this insanity
will be the rotting bodies upon which
the sun will impartially shine tomorrow
let us throw down these guns that we
hate
with the morning we shall go together in
cl charity and hope and build a new life
and a new world
following his convalescence
cord began seeing a lot of mary meyer
they had known each other uh beforehand
but they had never really dated
seriously
and i think
for cord mary became
the roman candle
who not only demanded and supported his
vision of a world without war but also
shared an emerging focus
on how to convince the masses of its
rightness
and this was really what drew marianne
cord together
cord became very interested in the new
u.n
united nations and that would its
charter in 19 charter meeting in 1945 in
san francisco but he knew it wasn't
going to go far enough and that's when
he got involved with something called
the united world federalists that really
wanted to take the united nations
principle to a much higher level
where they could monitor throughout the
globe hot spots that were taking place
intervene in an appropriate way and
defuse the situation
unfortunately this effort failed and in
1948 cord was seduced or started to get
seduced by alan dulles but he didn't
eventually
join the cia until the early 1930s
and it wasn't his first choice cord
really wanted to be a writer
and he could have easily been an
outstanding writer but he did not have
the courage in my opinion to take this
dream and follow his own accord with it
as he wrote in his
diary if i had more faith in my creative
talent
i would write
but he didn't
and so
in the early 1950s
he was allowed himself to be seduced by
alan dulles like many people in his
generation
and that's where
the beginning of the end of that
marriage and relationship took place
they finally divorced in 1957
and uh
court as we know
uh went on to deeper and darker pursuits
within the agency
and it eventually i think really just
killed his soul
it's very
interesting
that one of mary meyer's close friends
ann truits wrote in her in her book
later on in the 1980s
that
there was
a dynamic
uh
that she
came upon
um
with the men who came out of world war
ii and she wrote something
very perceptive and i'm going to read it
this is it quote confronted by the
probability of their own deaths it seems
to me that many of the most percipient
men of my generation
killed off those parts of themselves
that were most vulnerable to pain
and thus lost forever a delicacy of
feeling upon which intimacy depends
to a less tragic extent we women also
had to harden ourselves and stood to
lose with them the vulnerability that is
one of the guardians of the human spirit
i think you know
one of the misfortunes
uh
of the
kennedy era is that as
we know now
jfk had a lot of difficulty
with emotional intimacy he had a lot of
difficulty
uh with women
from a psychologist's point of view
he would have what i would call a bona
fide sexual addiction
but there was a clearing that was taking
place
and i think
jack's relationship with mary meyer was
in fact a relationship of redemption and
that's what i like to call it sometimes
mary understood that jfk's conflicted
hunger as perhaps only a uniquely
enlightened woman could
she viewed some of his
sexual wanderlusts for what it was a
symptom of his unresolved anger and
hatred of the rejection that he had been
forced to endure from an empty cold and
distant mother
and it was clear
uh in my research and people that i
talked to
that in
their relationship together
um mary really laid down the law so to
speak it was not a situation of anything
goes
she demanded
jack's self-esteem examination she
demanded that he open his eyes his heart
his soul the core of his being to both
the artifice and the reality of his
existence including his sexual
promiscuity
she
would have refused to allow him to hide
behind his physical incapacity his sense
of obligation to his father or the
kennedy family his fear of public
ridicule or any indifference to such
issues as civil rights and the dangers
of the cold war
she would have taken him to task in a
way that some part of him
actually longed for
knowing the emotional pain he would have
to confront
in order to reclaim himself jack would
have had to have had
be willing to experience the grief and
emotional and tendency to some to
experience what mary herself had faced
with the loss of her son michael
you see mary knew the drill the crashing
surf of unbearable sorrow and what was
required to survive it
this was a woman who would have been
once
tender and firm with him
yet demanding
that he show up engage and stop running
i think for jack mary likely represented
the hope of a lost love a magnetic
magnetic
romantic passion
the kind of erotic chemistry he had once
experienced with the woman in inga arvad
tempered by the same kind of no [ __ ]
heartfelt bond that he had shared with
his departed sister kathleen
aware of mary's multi-dimensional beauty
and allure from across the room at one
of the white house dinner dances in in
february 1962
jack had leaned in and commented to his
be friend ben bradley quote mary would
be rough to live with
and according to bradley this wasn't the
first time he had made this comment and
as bradley noted and i agreed this was
not the first time
there wasn't any doubt that jfk's remark
revealed something about the nature of
his relationship with mary there were
undoubtedly moments was when mary was in
fact rough to live with but something in
jack had been awakened by mary an end an
entrance into his life something that
kept him engaged and apparently wanting
more
such was the fire and hope not only of
love's redemption but of a more clearly
defined reclamation of himself and the
kind of president he wanted to become
jfk's closest advisor kenny o'donnell
had confided in the late author author
du leo de
that mary had been quite outspoken for
instance and confrontational with the
when the president decide was about to
resume nuclear testing in april 1962
quote she openly challenged him to do
something different
not fall into the trap of getting in a
pissing contacts test with the russians
said leo damore to me in 1992
based on what o'donnell had said to him
according to damore o'donnell sometimes
even feared mary because of the power
she had over jack telling damore that
the president would sometimes feverishly
pace around the oval office when he
wasn't able to get in touch with mary
but vulnerability isn't necessarily the
sign of weakness very often it's the
emerging strength of a healing heart
crying out for connection
mary had a surrender serenity about her
reflected ben bradley in an interview
with me in in 2009
she was a serious person if she fell in
love with somebody i suspect that person
was really loved
when we look at what other people have
written about mary
i'm
go to her herb parmet's ground bit
breaking 1983 biography of jack
and he had interviewed a close uh
confidential source i think it probably
was kenny o'donnell but he said this
about mary quote
he could talk in ways with her she
understood and their trust was mutual
when he was with her the rest of the
world could go to hell he could laugh
with her at the absurdity of all the
things he saw around his center of power
most striking toward the end of 1962 at
the after the end of the cuban missile
crisis inside the white house mary meyer
had become almost a part of the
furniture
in the words of white house counsel
meyer feldman according to what
he told author nina burley
quote unlike some of the other women and
men in the white house the president did
not ask her to leave the room when he
discussed business wrote early
so frequent was her proximity to the
president and so obvious
kennedy's admiration for her that
feldman felt that he might make a good
conde
conduit to the president's ear if and
when
it was unavailable to discuss matters of
state with him in fact mary's emerging
presence in the white house was more
than just
documented in the entry logs
said feldman again i'd walk out of the
office all the time and i would see her
in the oval office or over at the
residence around 8 30 in the evening
when the day was over i'd walk over to
the residence and she'd be sitting there
there wasn't any attempt to hide her the
way there was with some of the other
women
just as fascinating was mary's evolving
position
within the kennedy white house itself
the senior staff
never seemed she was never regarded as
second tier
mention of her name even might be
considered advantageous for employment
in the opinion in the opinion of arthur
schlesinger here's a memorandum that
schlesinger wrote to kennedy
at the end of
62 when they were discussing writing the
history that they wanted written of the
bay of pigs and schlesinger saying look
i know this historian trumbull higgins
but mary meyer knows her
much better than i do
and uh i'm sure you can get a clearer
indication
from
her as to if he'd be suitable or not
as we've talked about today the day
june 10th 1963
was
a
major life event
for jfk himself and probably for our
country as well
what we don't know
much about was the fact of what happened
that evening after he gave that speech
the american university commencement
address had become a watershed divining
a moment in which this visionary
president decided to take the world in a
profoundly different direction
it's breathtaking to behold the kind of
courage and leadership that our 35th
president began to embrace that day
and so i asked the question had the muse
of mary meyer finally found its true
object of transformation
that evening of june 10th had also
brought with it a small private
celebration
just before 8 pm
at next to the last minute
with jackie away at camp david
jfk decided to stop by his friend joe
alsop's house in georgetown
opting to come quote just for a drink
the president would stay for more than
an hour as guests for allsup's dinner
party began to arrive
you can imagine who was also there
mary meyer was already there and i'm
almost as certain jfk she knew she would
be
if as joe also described it jack was
quote in a gay mood that early
june evening you can bet that mary
herself must have been ablaze and not
just because of flowers and bloom
everywhere were coaxing her to smile
on that day
jack had ventured
to go where cordmire would never have
gone
her mission had become illuminated into
her mosaic a subliminal peace song whose
emerging
though still faint melody had just
premiered for all mankind earlier that
day
during cocktails in the alpha garden
mary sat with jack on one side and
ambassador bill atwood her prep school
bow and college bow on the other
bill atwood
would recall three years later
that on that evening the three of them
had turned to the enjoyable recollection
of past events quote reminiscing about
our old school days
with mary as his date at chote and how
jack had quote happily recalled having
cut in
on them on the dance floor
said atwood it was hard at times like
that to realize that he was president of
the united states
and it was impossible to imagine that
inside of a year
both of them would be murdered he in
dallas and she in georgetown
okay i just been told
i only have five minutes
left that's unfortunate time flies when
you're having fun
what i wanted to say
uh was
the next part of my talk was and this
will be posted was to talk about the
focal points of the cia that alan dulles
arranged with fletcher prouty and to
underscore the fact that there was a
copycat assassination attempt on jfk on
november 2nd in chicago
it was an exact replica
of what happened
uh in dallas
three weeks later
and it was suppressed we never learned
about what took place
until
the assassinations record review board
demanded that the secret service turn
over the records and at that very point
the secret service destroyed all the
records so that we never knew from the
secret service point of view of what
actually happened
i also wanted to say
that in my pursuit of this story
to get to where i have gotten and this
will there will not be another edition i
promise you uh
i had to jump through a lot of
hoops and make a lot of sacrifices
and i never could have really gotten to
the bottom of who lieutenant william
mitchell was and what his role was in in
the assassination of mary had i not had
some help
from a very special person who came into
my life who helped me uh since 2004 get
to the bottom of how to look at this
story and what was really going on so
when we i i won't spoil it by telling
you the story i think it's a it's a
genuinely interesting read particularly
the last two chapters of the third
edition
and that's where you will learn
that there was a focal point office uh
where william mitchell worked in the
pentagon and
his
boss
which was lieutenant ralph heller
crookshank was was part of the operation
to take mary out as was mitchell i doubt
if mitchell knew of any of the other
people on the team he had one job and
that was to frame ray crump which he
attempted to do very professionally the
next day but he failed
because what they didn't count on
was uh
w roundtree the incredible
african-american attorney who realized
that mr trump was being railroaded in
this case
so
finally when we
procured the documents that we procured
we
were able to realize
that
mitchell's oath of office took place on
june 11th in 1962 the same day of his
cornell university graduation and his
rotc graduation at cornell he was absent
he was in suitland he had a used car
salesman sign his oath of office because
directly across the street in the
suitland federal bearing was a secret
office of the cia where we believe he
was getting inducted so to speak in
terms of
what his actual role would be when he
went into the army so that is his oath
of office
there you can see
that mitchell
is being sent to the defense
intelligence agency after swearing in a
deposition that he had no connection
with any kind of intelligence agency
ever
and here
is his locator card showing that he
arrived at
the uh
defense intelligence agency
so i want to just uh to take i've been
told i have one minute now
i want
i want to introduce you to the person
who was just indispensable to me in
figuring all of this out his name is
roger charles
he
has had a near 30-year career as a
journalist he's investigated
such diverse subjects as the detainee
abuse at abu ghraib he's a peaboard
peabody award-winning journalist he's
the author of the definitive book on the
oklahoma city bombing and he is a whiz
kid when it comes to
looking at documents intelligent
documents military documents and
understanding uh
what was really taking place and what
roger says you can read right there in
terms of the very end of my book
he puts his stamp of approval on where
this journey finally took to me and uh
as roger says he believes that it's
pretty clear that mr mitchell was in
some way connected to the cia so roger i
wonder if you would just stand up and
let people see you and
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
there
okay jefferson morley
jefferson morley is the moderator of
jfkfax.org
which i consider one of the best if not
the best websites that cover news
relating to john kennedy and the kennedy
assassination
he worked as an editor and reporter at
the washington post the nation the new
republic and harper's magazine
his work has appeared in the new york
review of books the new york times book
review the washington post book world
reader's digest rolling stone and slate
his first book was our man in mexico
winston scott and the hidden history of
the cia
his book
his book snowstorm in august details
what happened when the anti-slavery
movement first came to washington d.c
during andrew johnson's presidency
jeff is also the author of fff's
best-selling ebook cia and jfk the
secret assassination files
his newest book a biography of james
jesus angleton cia chief of cia
counterintelligence from
to
1954-1907
will be published by saint martin's
press later this year
the title of jeff's talk is angleton
cuba and assassination jeff morley
[Applause]
hi thank you all thank you jacob um for
that introduction and
setting up this marvelous event
which i find myself learning something
new
with every speaker
um i hope to reward and thank you all
for coming
i've met a lot of people who i only knew
by email
it's always gratifying to meet people in
person not digitally
so thank you for your coming i hope to
reward your interest by telling you a
story about james angleton the chief of
counterintelligence of the central
intelligence agency during the kennedy
administration
um this story speaks directly to some of
the themes that we've already heard um
this describes the actions of the cia as
kennedy pursued the strategy of peace
that jeffrey sachs
talked about
it illuminates the reality of double
government that michael glennon talked
about
and it adds some new details about
operation north woods which doug horn
talked about
so um i couldn't have given this
presentation or learned this story
without the help of several people and i
want to thank them
first of all john newman uh who
introduced me to the oswald the cia's
oswald file more than 20 years ago
uh malcolm blunt who came all the way
from england to attend this conference
who explicated some of the puzzles that
we find in that file
and bill sempich who alerted me to one
of the key stories in there
i want to emphasize before i start also
that
nothing that i say in this
talk depends on a conspiratorial
interpretation
of the uh assassination of president
kennedy um if i'm not going to try
whatever your opinion i'm not going to
try and dissuade you from it or convince
you of something else
i don't really have a theory of the
kennedy assassination at least not one
that i talk about in public
if you buy me a drink later maybe i'll
share one
if you buy me two drinks i'll show you
two um but that's not what i came here
to talk about i didn't come to talk
about
theories i came to talk about facts and
everything that i say in this
presentation
is empirical fact
the fact is james angleton was a
was the embodiment of cold war espionage
and has become that in our popular
culture he's a historic world historic
important figure that you may think you
know something about
and so you should and you should buy my
forthcoming book the ghost the secret
life of cia spymaster james jesus
angleton which will be in bookstores in
october
angleton deserves his legend
he was an extraordinarily influential
figure in the american government during
the cold war a veritable founding father
of the cia
all of 30 years old when the cia was
founded in 1947 he spent the next three
decades distinguishing himself elevating
himself into a position of
transcendental influence on the u.s
government
he had a vast array of contacts from the
ivy league to the vatican to organize
crime to the masons to the mossad he
cultivated a deep knowledge of the
soviet intelligence services
the cheka the mkvd and the kgb
and he knew how to ingratiate himself
with men of power like alan dulles j
edgar hoover and richard nixon
as chief of the agency's
counterintelligence staff from 1954 to
1974
he established a fiefdom of secret
operations within the cia a cia within
the cia
that virtually no one in the elected
government of the united states knew
about and he ran it for 20 years in
angleton's story we find both a chilling
cold war drama and a pivotal moment in
the evolution of u.s government and the
emergence of the american national
security state
the gist of my argument today will
strike most people in this room as
more common sensical than original
the kennedy's assassination was a
decisive moment
in the evolution of the american nation
national security state i only want to
take this time to make that point with
slightly more precision
it was the aftermath of jfk's
assassination that was the pivotal
moment at least as far as the
consolidation of the national security
regime went
and angleton was a key figure in that
moment
the assassination in dallas was a moment
of great danger for the cia
if the agency or any of its employees
had been held responsible for the
wrongful death of the president its
powers might have been curbed
the clandestine service might have been
abolished as president as former
president harry truman
urged one month after jfk's murder
if the cia's role in the events leading
up to dallas had been shared with the
congress and the american people the
ambitions and the prerogatives of the
national security state might have been
checked
that did not happen
thanks in no small part to james
angleton
my story has three strands and i'm going
to summarize them before i explain them
the first is angleton's mole hunt
this was his search for a kgb spy in the
ranks of the cia and as he hunted for
the mole he monitored the movements of a
defector to the soviet union named lee
oswald
the second is angleton's largely unknown
role in jfk's cuba policy
angleton discussed the assassination of
fidel castro as early as 1961
and he advised the pentagon on regime
change policies in 1963.
the two strands intersected in the fall
of 1963 when oswald showed up in mexico
city at the cuban consulate in the
russian embassy angleton staff was
immediately notified
and the third strand of the story grows
out of the first two
how and why angleton hid what he knew
about oswald from the warren commission
the congress and the public with
consequences that we are still grappling
with today
now let us begin at the beginning
jim angleton and jack kennedy were born
six months apart in 2019-17
as with jfk 2017 is the centennial of
angleton's birth
angleton and kennedy both came from
families newly wealthy families and they
inherited the privileges of money
foreign travel and an ivy league
education
they both embodied the they both
embodied the aspirations and the fears
of the american elite after world war ii
and indeed they knew each other
angleton and his wife sicily lived on
glebe wrote lived just off glebe road in
north arlington and they were social
friends with john and jackie kennedy who
lived in georgetown like many others the
angletons found the kennedy is
enormously attractive
jfk's ironic charm reminded cicely
angleton of a certain shakespearean
aristocrat
when kennedy was elected president in
november 1960 she wrote to a friend
prince hamlet is in the white house
by the time of kennedy's election
angleton was already knowledgeable about
lee harvey oswald
his interest had been prompted by the
arrest of one of the cia's most valuable
spies in the soviet union a man named
peter popov
popoff was a soviet intelligence officer
who had been feeding the agency up a
stream of information about the red army
for years
in october 1959 october 19th or 20th
popoff was arrested he was later tried
and executed
in the offices of the cia then housed in
a series of temporary buildings along
the reflecting pool on the national mall
the cia men debated what had gone wrong
bill harvey chief of cia berlin base
thought popoff had been exposed by the
sloppy tradecraft of one of his moscow
handlers
so did bill hood another senior officer
who was involved in the handling of
pop-off
angleton disagreed
he suspected popoff had been betrayed
from within by what he called a mole a
spy within the ranks of the cia itself
and angleton's suspicion soon hardened
into a fixed idea which fueled his
legendary mole hunt
it all began with peter popov's arrest
said cia's in-house historian david
robarge after that angleton became
fixated on the mole
it was
not coincidentally it was two weeks
after popoff's arrest that the paper
trail connecting angleton to oswald
one of angleton's most trusted staff
members
was a woman named jane roman she served
as his liaison officer handling all
communications with other federal
agencies
on november 2nd 1959 in her daily call
with sam papich the fbi's liaison to the
agency pappage asked her about a story
that had appeared on a seven of the
previous of the washington post on the
previous saturday ex-marine asked soviet
citizenship
the wire service reported that a
20-year-old former marine from texas
named lee harvey oswald had shown up at
the u.s embassy in moscow and announced
his intention to become a soviet citizen
when roman received a cable about oswald
from the state department the next day
she scrawled on top mr pappage would
like to know about this ex-marine who
recently defected into the ussr
oswald was an obvious target of the
counterintelligence staff interest it
wasn't unheard of for an american to
move to moscow in 1959 but it was
certainly unusual
roman
seen here
routed the cable to her colleague birch
o'neill the chief of an office known as
the special investigations group the sig
as it was known was responsible for
keeping files on defectors
o'neill services supervised the staff of
eight people including a woman named
betty eggetter she was the master of the
office filing system editor described
the special investigations group as the
office that spied on spies
the sig was the operational arm of
angleton's mole hunt and not
coincidentally the sig controlled
oswald's file
the proof of angleton's interest in
oswald can be seen in the ci's unusual
handling of his defection
standard cia procedure called for the
opening of a personality file known in
the lingo of many federal agencies as a
201 file
the cia central file registry had tens
of thousands of 201 files some of them
fat some of them thin
some of them filled with classified
information some of them holding only a
couple of newspaper clippings
oswald an ex-marine with a security
clearance who had threatened to share
military secrets with the enemy
certainly qualified for a 201 file
nonetheless the special investigations
group chose not to open a 201 file on
him instead on december 9 1959 the
office of security opened a file on
oswald labeled os 351 164 this file then
became the repository of all information
received about oswald
needless to say the office of security
did not create oswald's file without
consulting angleton's staff
the sig served as quote a liaison office
between the ci staff and the office of
security betty eggetter later explained
we worked very closely with the office
of security
in the case of oswald the unusual
procedure had to be approved at the
highest level
robert bannerman who served as deputy
director of the office security in 1959
told historian john newman
jim angleton was in on this
angleton's interest in oswald was finely
tuned the effect of creating an os file
instead of a 201 file was to ensure that
information about the ex-marine was held
more tightly
so
if someone inside the agency
like the kgb mold that oswal that
angleton thought was working in his
midst
wanted to know more about the ex-marine
whose defection the washington post had
reported
he would have to ask for the file in
writing
provide a name office and phone number
if there was a 201 file that paper trail
would not have been created
by creating a restricted os file and not
a 201 file oswald could determine who in
the ranks of the cia was interested in
him
the unusual handling of the oswald file
was one of angleton's techniques for
searching for the mole whom he thought
had betrayed peter popoff
in october 1960 the state department
sent a notice to the cia stating that it
wanted up-to-date records on all recent
defectors
that missive according to the cia's
account prodded the central the
counterintelligence staff to act
in december 1960 a year after oswald's
defection betty edgar completed the
paperwork to create a 201 file for
oswald
it now contained a dozen items four
memos from the state department two from
cia two from fbi one from the office of
naval intelligence and three newspaper
clippings
for the next three years all reports on
oswald from anywhere in the federal
government would be routed to the sig
and into the file controlled by betty
eggetter
now let's turn to cuba
after the election of john kennedy in
november 1960 angleton became more
involved in the agency's operations in
cuba
more involved than i knew before i wrote
this book and more involved than
scholars and any scholars and
journalists have known until now
unlike his liberal friends angleton was
immune to the notion that fidel castro
was a nationalist or a social reformer
with whom the united states could do
business
after the humiliation of the bay of pigs
in april 1961 angleton was drawn more
deeply into cuba operations on may 4th
1961
the national security council tasked him
with a new job to quote create train and
support a highly motivated and
professionally competent apolitical and
career security service which will be
dedicated to the preservation of the
dead of the democratic forum of
government
angleton in short was in charge of
creating an intelligence service for
post-castro cuba
to that end angleton discussed
assassinating castro in november 1961
angleton and bill harvey now chief of
the cia's cuba task force met with peter
wright a scientist who worked for the
british equivalent of the fbi the mi5
in his memoir spy catcher wright said
harvey grilled him about how the cia
pursued assassination of its enemies
angleton took such careful notes that
wright began to have qualms and second
thoughts
quote the site of angleton's notebook
was beginning to unnerve me they seemed
so determined so convinced that this was
the way to handle castro and i was
slightly put out that i could not help
more
angleton questioned president kennedy's
cuba policies especially after the
missile crisis of 1962.
when the cia's overflights confirmed the
construction of
missile silos in cuba kennedy went
public with the intelligence and
demanded their removal
while the joint chiefs and most of
kennedy's
civilian advisers of we've heard before
recommended an immediate invasion
kennedy played for time privately he
promised soviet premier nikki to
khrushchev that he would not invade the
island and the soviet leader fearing a
wider war ordered the dismantling of the
middle missiles
on the brink of what might have been a
nuclear holocaust kennedy had produced
peace
his popularity surged the democrats did
much better than expected in the 1962
midterm elections
but kennedy also encountered a riptide
of resentment from the military and
intelligence agencies quote the
president emerged with his credibility
and prestige measurably enhanced wrote
pentagon historian stephen reardon in
his official history of the joint chiefs
of staff
but
to end the crisis he made compromises
and concessions that his military
advisers considered in many ways
unnecessary and excessive
the consensus on the joint chiefs of
staff was that the united states had
come out the poorer end of the bargain
angleton shared this view
late in life he wrote that kennedy had
fumbled away a chance to to liberate
cuba quote there was first kennedy's
unmistakable faltering of will at the
bay of pigs followed 18 months later by
his reluctance to make good the showdown
an exact fair price for the missile
crisis by forcing castro's expulsion
from cuba
for having conspired with the kremlin to
bring soviet nuclear power into the
western hemisphere
for jim angleton his wife's analogy to
of jfk to hamlet was apt
like the danish prince the american
president was intelligent self-absorbed
and indecisive
in angleton's view he lacked will and
the united states was weaker for it
in mid 1963 engleton made his most
important contribution to cuba policy a
secret working paper entitled cuban
control and action capabilities
this document was not provided by the
cia it was found by in the pentagon
records by the assassination records
review board it was declassified in 1997
as doug horn
talked earlier
for angleton and advocates of
overthrowing castro this was a
disheartening time the spring of 1963.
in march attorney general bob kennedy
ordered the fbi to crack down on cuban
exiles who were using south florida as a
base for attacks
on ships doing business with cuba the
cuban colony in miami exploded in
outrage the cuban revolutionary council
the cia-funded umbrella organization
that was supposed to constitute the new
government in havana dissolved an
acrimonious denunciation of the
president
many military intelligence officials
were concerned that the soviet union was
solidifying its foothold in the western
hemisphere while kennedy was pursuing a
nuclear test ban treaty with the soviets
that the joint chiefs thought was
ill-advised
in a meeting on may 1 1963 the joint
chiefs of staff resurrected the secret
plan for cuba known by the deceptively
bucolic code name north woods
the northwoods plans as doug uh
explained earlier involved were first
developed after the bay of pig's pro
fiasco they sought to create a
justification a pretext for a u.s
invasion the pentagon planners on may
first 1963 recommended what they called
quote an engineered provocation
saying that a violent incident that
could be blamed on castro would have
advantages in quote control
timing simplicity and security
the chiefs passed on their
recommendation secretary of defense
robert mcnamara who ignored it he knew
that president kennedy and his brother
were not interested uh did not want to
overthrow castro by
in invasion the kennedys preferred the
idea of autonomous operations against
castro guerrilla attacks launched from
outside the united states
with u.s policy in flux angleton
contributed an assessment of the cuban
target
what were cuba's capabilities what were
its weaknesses what would the u.s
military have to overcome in order to
retake cuba from the communists
angleton studied the files and he wrote
up his findings in a there were actually
three documents a 16-page working paper
and two other attached documents and on
may 23 1963 he distributed this document
to the joint chiefs of staff and the
heads of 15 federal agencies
in the cover in this cover letter
angleton stated that this was not merely
a provisional statement on the cuban
situation but was an all-source
assessment of the communist control
system
angleton intended his paper to serve as
nothing less as the foundation of a new
national policy to eliminate the castro
regime in 1963 or 1964.
the cuban capabilities memo in my view
is one of the most important documents
bearing angleton's name to ever surface
it confirms his leading role in cuba
policy in 1963 while demonstrating
something of his intellectual power
angleton's analysis of the strengths of
the castro government was lucid detailed
historical and comprehensive
angleton asserted that kennedy's no
invasion pledge had demoralized castro's
foes he said that the cuban leader had
emerged stronger from the october crisis
with up to four hundred thousand men and
women now sermon in the militias the
army and the navy
another ball work of support for the
regime he noted were friendship
societies in the united states and other
countries which sent sympathizers to the
island
who returned indoctrinated with
pro-communist messages or perhaps with
missions of sabotage espionage and
assassination
in the course of his research angleton
had reviewed multiple reports of
travelers who had wished to conceal
their visits to cuba
and he wrote an american citizen for
example can enter mexico with a tourist
card not even a passport and obtain a
separate visa to travel to cuba from the
cuban consulate in mexico city
he can go to cuba and return supplied
with a new tourist card obtained in cuba
without any indication that he has ever
been there
this was remarkably prescient that is
exactly what the defector lee oswald
would attempt to do four months later
enter mexico with a tourist card
go to the cuban consulate in mexico city
and seek a visa to travel to
cuba thus angleton's memo is also an
important document in the kennedy in the
record of the assassination of president
kennedy
the memo reveals angleton's knowledge of
and interest in
americans traveling to cuba via mexico
and via the cuban consulate in mexico
city in particular
it illuminates and confirms the fact
that angleton hid for the rest of his
life
when lee harvey oswald showed up at the
cuban consulate in mexico city in
september 1963
angleton was not surprised he was not
uninformed he was prepared
let me pause here
this moment 1963 angleton was also
witting to ongoing efforts of the cia to
assassinate castro
uh this is one of the best stories and i
i like this story because angleton
himself is the source of it
in june 1963 an fbi surveillance team at
national airport was following a mafia
don named johnny roselli who the cia had
enlisted in the plots to kill castro
rosselli got off his plane he got into a
car and the fbi agents were astonished
to realize that the driver
was none other than bill harvey
former chief of the cia's cuba task
force and now serving allegedly as the
station chief in rome
the fbi agents called sam pappage the
still the liaison to the agency to
complain what was a cia a top ucia
official doing consorting with a mafia
boss who incidentally was suspected in
no less than 13 murders
the fbi when the fbi agents called
pavich they discovered that he was at
angleton's house having dinner
pappage took the call he put the phone
down he turned angled he said what
should i do and angleton said
let's go easy on this
the fbi surveillance team was called off
and people wondered did angleton know
what harvey and rosselli were talking
about at duke ziebert's restaurant
when harvey was asked that when angleton
was asked that question about harvey he
said
i knew he was not a frivolous man
angleton's people had not forgotten
about lee harvey oswald in 1963.
all u.s government reporting on him
still went into the sig file controlled
by betty eggetter
and now that that file contained a state
department cable on oswald's marriage to
a russian woman in minsk in 1961
there was a navy memo about his plans to
return to the united states with his
wife in may 1962
there was an fbi interview with a surly
and uncooperative oswald outside his
home in fort worth texas in august 1963.
if oswald was indeed a lone nut as
cliche would later have it he was that
rare isolated sociopath who was of
intense interest to the cia's
counterintelligence staff
needless to say angleton paid attention
when j edgar hoover sent him three more
reports about oswald in the fall of
1963.
the first
an fbi member from dallas arrived in
angleton's office on september 24th
jane roman signed for it fbi agent james
hosti reported that oswald drank to
excess and beat his wife
and had once passed out leaflets for the
pro-castro fair play for cuba committee
one of those friendship societies that
angleton had identified in his cuban
capabilities memo
two weeks later jane roman signed for
another fbi report oswald had been
arrested in new orleans while passing
out fpcc leaflets the ex-marine had
gotten into a heated argument with three
members of an anti-caster organization
and he was arrested for disturbing the
peace
so when a third report on oswald came
clattering in by teletype on tuesday
afternoon
october 8th
angleton paid attention
from mexico city
station chief win scott said a man
calling himself lee oswald had contacted
a consular officer at the soviet embassy
scott's cable let's see if we can get
that here
scott's cable was slugged lc improve and
you can see that at the top lc improve
was the code name for quote counter
espionage involving soviet intelligence
services worldwide
angleton's undisputed domain
other cables read by angleton's
successor george colarus reported that
oswald had visited the cuban consulate
in other words
in other words this was a national
security event
affected the soviet union known to the
counterintelligence staff for four years
and now active on behalf of a pro-castro
organization that had been targeted for
destruction by the fbi and the cia
had visited the cuban consulate in
mexico city which angleton himself had
cited as a locus of cuba regime
activities
okay angleton had not forgotten about
the cuban consulate in the four months
since he wrote his cuban capabilities
memo when a character like oswald showed
up at the cuban consulate this was very
important
and it was treated as such at cia
headquarters angleton staff responded
within 48 hours
on october 10th jane roman drafted and
sent a cable to other agencies in
washington
fbi oni state department
reporting that oswald
wrongly described as six foot tall and
35 years old had been overheard
contacting the russians in mexico city
then
later that afternoon roman and betty
eggetter drafted a second cable
this one addressed to win scott in
mexico city
they showed a draft
this is the
the bottom of the the the cable
indicates who signed on it so
roman jane roman had it in draft
and she wrote that and then she showed
it to betty eggetter
and then they took it to john witten the
chief of the
west of the mexico desk
and he signed off as well and then they
took it to angleton's friend bill hood
who was serving as chief of operations
for the western hemisphere and he signed
off
and then they took it to tom cara
messines the trusted deputy of
the trusted assistant to deputy director
dick helms
and he signed off
to be sure
angleton's name does not appear on this
cable
but the five subordinates who produced
it did not act in defiance of his wishes
or without his knowledge not if they
cared about their security clearances
their job security their pensions or
their reputations
curiously
the second cable said nothing about
oswald's recent arrest in new orleans or
his activities on behalf of the fpcc
with the latest fbi reports on jane
roman's desk angleton's people could
have described oswald as a law breaking
communist with and sometimes violent
supporter of fidel castro
instead the cable to scott was curiously
reassuring
the agency had not received any new
information on oswald since his return
from the soviet union a year and a half
ago according to the cable let's go back
and look at that
latest headquarters information was a
state department report dated may 1962
state had determined oswald is still a
u.s citizen and his soviet wife have
exit permits and state department
approval for their travel with their
infant child
if the october 10 cable was to be
believed and when scott believed it the
cia had gathered no information on
oswald since his return from the soviet
union 17 months before
that to put it plainly was a lie the
cable was deceptive as jane roman would
later admit when i interviewed at her
house in washington when i showed her a
copy of the the cable she said yeah i'm
signing off on something that isn't true
i went to see bill hood then living in
retirement on long island and asked him
about the cable why didn't the cia share
the most recent fbi reporting on oswald
with scott
hood fell silent
after after a brief sign he said i don't
think there's anything smelly in it
which i thought was a curious comment
and then he added i don't see a master
hand in it well if there was a master
hand it was angleton's the cia's latest
headquarters information on oswald was
not 17 months old it was too much it was
less than two weeks old
in the execution of a secret operation
angleton's omission would have been
justified if oswald's cuba related
activities in 1963 were somehow part of
an authorized covert operation
then wynn scott had no need to know
about them
which begs the question was angleton
running oswald as an agent for some
intelligence purpose
he certainly had the knowledge and
ability to do so
he was searching for a mole
he and his staff had a granular
knowledge of oswald's life his movements
his family and his political views
angleton had a penchant for running
operations outside of normal reporting
channels
he articulated a vigilant anti-communism
that depicted the results of jfk's
liberal policies in apocalyptic terms
he participated in discussions of
assassination
and he worked in a penumbra of cunning
that his admirers did not fail to
mention
quote angleton possessed a unique grasp
of secret operations dick helms wrote in
his memoir
jim had the ability to raise an
operational discussion not only to a
higher level
but to another dimension
in 1963 1964 and even into the 1970s
james angleton could plausibly deny the
existence
of an operation involving oswald
those denials are much less plausible
today
as to the nature and purpose of this
operation if there was one we are only
left to speculate i can only say it most
likely concerned what concerned angleton
which was the mole hunt and the effort
to change the regime in cuba via an
engineered provocation
in any case
the time stamp on the cable indicates
angleton's omission with precision
10 october 1963 5 29 pm washington time
at that moment president kennedy was
finishing up a busy day in the in the
oval office he'd spent the morning with
his national security advisers and he
ended the day conferring with two
leaders of newly imp independent african
nations
he had 42 days to live
within a week of oswald's visit to
mexico city and this is this is new uh
this is what bill simpitch alerted me to
and i think it's important angleton
launched a mole hunt in mexico
this molehunt underscores a reality
that's largely been unknown to people
who follow angleton
that the mole hunt extended beyond the
soviet russia division
it reached into mexico city into the
very offices that had been watching and
reporting on lee oswald
in the fall of 1963 these d-class
declassified records unearthed by
simpage show that angleton was worried
about the cia's mexico opera that the
cia's mexico operations may have been
compromised by an fbi informant of the
code name lay rob
who was actually in angleton's view
possibly a soviet double agent
angleton's friend bill hood chief of
operations in the western hemisphere
then ordered an office of security team
to interrogate the mexican employees of
the cia offices in mexico city and
monterey
the first three employees who were
questioned on october 8 1963 were the
three men who manned the surveillance
points that watched the soviet and cuban
diplomatic offices in mexico city the
very offices that oswald had visited the
week before
whether these men were asked about
oswald is unknown
the interrogators filed a report on each
person who they questioned in during the
mexico mole hunt and the result was 21
reports on 21 different employees and
with each report came an attachment that
described the contents of the interview
what what they were actually questioned
about
of the 21 reports that are now found in
the jfk records collection the
attachments are missing on 18 of them
the mole hunt in mexico city was
completed between october 8 and october
18th the results were analyzed in
washington
and the results were sent to bill hood
and to angleton in early november
the office of security found some
security breaches
some loose talk among family members but
no type of compromise like that was
feared by angleton as far as the office
of security was concerned there was no
mole in mexico city
all the while lee oswald remained a
figure of interest
on november 15th jane roman signed for
the latest fbi report
on oswald from new orleans senior agent
warren dubroys had filed a more detailed
memo on oswald's pro-castro activities
if angleton scanned the first page he
learned that oswald had gone back to
texas after his trip to mexico city
angleton knew that oswald was in mexico
city and he knew now that he was back in
fort worth
angleton always sought to give the
impression that he knew very little
about lee oswell before november 22
1963.
for the chief of the agency's
counterintelligence staff that was a
frail defense
his staff had monitored oswald's
movements for four years as the former
marine moved from moscow to minsk to
fort worth to new orleans to mexico city
and then to dallas the special
investigations group received reports on
him every step of the way by the time
president kennedy was preparing for a
trip to dallas
angleton knew oswald was in texas
you can interpret that however you want
the plain fact is that an epic
counterintelligence failure culminated
on angleton's watch
there's no evidence that angleton knew
the president's life was in danger
before november 22nd
there's overwhelming evidence that
angleton had much to hide when oswald
was arrested for gunning down jack
kennedy in broad daylight
and there's no doubt that angleton
succeeded in hiding most of that
evidence
let's talk about the cover-up
after kennedy's assassination that day
deputy director dick helms put john
whitton chief of the mexico desk in
charge of collating all reports on
oswald
everything that had been learned
angleton did not offer any evidence or
theories of kgb involvement he didn't
argue that castro was behind oswald he
just tried to thwart john whitton
quote in the early stages mr angleton
was not able
to influence the course of the
investigation written testified in
secret
set session years later he was extremely
embittered that i was entrusted with the
investigation and he wasn't
in a meeting with witten and helms on
christmas eve 1963 angleton attacked the
latest draft on witten's report on
oswald as erroneous and unacceptable
helms relieved witten on the spot and
put angleton in charge of the oswald
investigation
quote helms wanted somebody to conduct
the investigation who was in bed with
the fbi whitten snorted i was not and
angleton was
angleton's power had reached a peculiar
apex
the ambush in dallas marks the worst
intelligence failure of the united
states since december 7th 1941 when the
japanese attacked pearl harbor and it
happened on angleton's watch
yet such was his bureaucratic stealth
that he managed to wind up in charge of
the agency's investigation of the
accused assassin
before jfk's death angleton's staff knew
more about lee oswald than just about
anyone in the u.s government
after the president was dead angleton
orchestrated the cover-up of what the
cia knew
one angleton
one advantage angleton had was that the
warren commission trusted the cia
in february 1964 the commission staff
learned that the cia had provided the
secret service with several cables on
the night of the assassination including
the october 10 cable that i referred to
before
the commission asked the agency to
produce the material
angleton resorted to deflection but he
needed helm's support to rebuff the
investigators
jim does not desire to respond directly
angleton's deputy ray rocket told helms
in a memo unless you feel otherwise jim
would prefer to wait out the commission
rather than turn over the cia's records
in their original form
jim would prefer to wait out the
commission
why on earth would a senior cia official
wait out the investigators of a
presidential assassination
roka claimed that there was nothing of
interest in the in the cables but of
course in intelligence work the source
of the information matters as much as
its content
the the cables included uh photographs
of people coming and going from the
cuban embassy and a passenger manifest
of people flying from mexico city
to havana
and what these documents showed was that
the cia had the ability and the desire
to photograph and identify every visitor
to the cuban consulate in mexico city to
identify every potential american
traveler to cuba
and the october 10 cable proved that
oswald was no exception
angleton preferred to wait out the
warren commission rather than explain
the cia's knowledge of and interest in
oswald
and particularly his visit to the cuban
consulate probably because that visit
involved some kind of covert operation
if they come back on the
howard williams oh if they came back on
the point raqqa told helms angleton
feels that you or someone should be
prepared to go over to the commission
with the materials and pass them rather
than pass them on in copy
howard williams an attorney for the
commission did come back on the point he
asked to see the original document he
was shown summaries instead
and he came away satisfied i consider
the cia representatives to be among the
more competent people in government who
i have ever dealt with he wrote in his
diary after meeting with raqqa they
articulate they are specialists
they do not have special access to grind
in the commission's investigation
willins never imagined the cia was
deceiving him on the fundamental facts
of the events leading to the death of
the president
in the fullness of time will willens
realized he'd been duped my journal
comments about the naive
about the cia were naive to say the
least williams told me the cia did have
access to grind in particular the willen
said the agency's failure to disclose
the plots to kill castro compromised the
warring commission
angleton participated in that cover-up
too
on may 8 1964 angleton received a memo
from hal swenson chief of
counterintelligence for the cuba
operations
swenson had learned from a reliable
source in the cuban armed forces that
castro had probably known about the
cia's recruitment of rolando cubella as
an assassin in 1963.
cubello
the amlash operation which was the code
name for the cubella operation might
have been the source of this might have
been an insecure operation prior to the
assassination of president kennedy
thus we know angleton was winning to
another plot to kill castro by may 1964
at least
the implications were obvious
if castro knew about the amlash plot
then he had a motive for killing kennedy
angleton chose not to investigate this
apparent breach of security he did not
turn swenson's memo over to the warren
commission indeed he seems to have
destroyed it which in any other homicide
investigation would have been tantamount
to obstruction of justice
when angleton was called to testify
about these events later he lied
when asked if oswald had ever been
interrogated when he returned from
russia angleton fumbled for words
i don't probably wouldn't i don't know i
just don't know whether the military
would normally fall within the
jurisdiction of the military since he
was a military man who defected
angleton babbled so i don't know the
answer to that
in fact angleton did know the answer the
fbi with inter interview with oswald in
the summer of 1962 had been sent to his
office betty egged or signed for it
when the attorneys for the house select
committee on assassination pressed him
about his knowledge of the castro
assassination plots angleton hedged the
question i want to ask you the attorney
asked is do you recall approximately
when you learned the information about
the castro assassination plots
before was it before or after the warren
commission i am certain angleton said
that it was well after the warren
commission compiled its work
that was perjury angleton's willingness
to violate the law is not is hard to
defend but it's not hard to understand
a serious counter-espionage
investigation of lee oswalt would have
uncovered angleton's abiding interest in
him it would have uncovered the various
operations toko castro it would have
revealed the damning fact that no matter
who fired the fatal shot in dallas
angleton had failed disastrously as
counterintelligence chief
to hide this sorry reality helms and
angleton fed the warren commission the
cover story that they knew very little
about oswald before the assassination
that the assad the cia didn't even know
that he had visited the cuban consulate
until after jfk was dead
that was a small but very telling lie
the fact that angleton knew that oswald
had visited the cuban consulate was
proof that oswald was a figure of
interest of intense interest in the fall
of 1963 it had to be denied suppressed
and erased from the record to sustain
the cover story of a lone nut
angleton could have and probably should
have lost his job after november 22nd
had the public the congress and the
warring commission known of his
pre-assassination interest in oswald and
his post-assassination cover-up he
surely would have
instead his malfeasance abetted by dick
helms went undetected
angleton would remain in a position of
supreme power for another decade
and so jim angleton came to embody the
untouchable power of the american
national security state after november
1963
thank you
is ron using one no where is he
yeah i see people taking a little
stretch so go ahead about a couple
minutes
really steady
okay
we're gonna start up again in two
minutes
yes
candy
okay we're ready to get started again if
you please take your seats
okay
all right we're ready with our next
speaker
ron paul
ron paul was a republican presidential
candidate in 2008 and 2012 and the
libertarian party presidential candidate
in 1988.
he served in the u.s house of
representatives from 1976 to 1977 from
79 to 85 and from 97 to 2013.
one of the country's most ardent
defenders of freedom
peace free markets and sound money paul
has long been a fierce critic of the
federal reserve system the irs the war
on drug
the war on drugs socialism empire
interventionism and the national
security establishment he has also been
an ardent defender of civil liberties
and a vocal critic of the usa patriot
act
torture indefinite detention and nsa
surveillance programs a graduate of
gettysburg college and duke university
school of medicine paul was a practicing
obstetrician gynecologist from the 60s
through the 80s the founder of the ron
paul institute paul is the author of
several books on austrian economics and
classical liberalism among which are the
case for gold a foreign policy of
freedom
in the fed pillars of prosperity the
revolution a manifesto swords into
plowshares and defined liberty and i
might add he is an absolute personal
hero of i think every libertarian in the
libertarian movement especially me
[Applause]
the title of ron's talk is enemies
foreign and domestic please welcome ron
paul
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you bumper and thank you for
inviting me you know when i was back in
washington i would give occasional
speeches i'd take time on a special
order you could get time five minutes
sometimes even up to an hour
and the one thing that happened with
those speeches i did my very best but i
never had any applause so
so i'm glad to come here and i get a
little pause once in a while so so i
need to boost my echo
[Applause]
so uh but
bumper it's great that uh you put this
together this is fantastic and uh
this organization the future freedoms
foundation a great organization if you
support it and you should because bumper
it's really good the only thing is i
have a little bit of question about him
he has all these fantastic speakers and
intellectuals and then he went and
invited a politician to come
so i don't know about that
but i want to tell you though bumper um
you did have a little competition for me
to get here i had this other invitation
it was really a tough choice uh there
was there was a meeting held matter of
fact in the area was over in chantilly i
don't know if you know what's going on
i would just in chile but uh you know i
was i was tempted to do that but then
again i got to thinking it would be much
better to be among friends and feel safe
and secure because at other places i
might not have felt so safe
but no it is it is great to be here and
of course the
title of my talk is you know defending
and support
the constitution of the united states
against all enemies
foreign and domestic of course many
people take that oath and sometimes i
get a little bit confused on that
because when i went to washington i
thought i had a pretty good
understanding about the constitution but
then you know
we would go back and forth it turned out
that my understanding was completely
wrong and they tried to convert me
but i had a little trouble listening to
their arguments they told me something
about the constitution should be more
flexible and it should be a living
document it shouldn't be overly rigid
and that's how you get into trouble so i
um i sort of struggled with that
tremendously and
then i got to thinking you know one
compliment that i get that i don't mind
getting this because
i think sometimes it's the compliments
are embellished a little bit more than
it need to be but the one is that how
did you go there how did you put up with
that nonsense and and not have to join
the gang because i was there for close
24 years and of course the one thing was
is my goals were different i didn't my
goal wasn't to be the chairman of the
committee because to do that you know
you have to sell your soul you have to
raise money
a few minor little things like uh like
that so uh
in my case i uh i i do believe that uh
when people say uh about me not joining
the gang is true matter of fact the
longer i was there the more i became
very skeptical of government per se
and i became more rigidly determined
that the problems not with the people as
much as it is with the government and
the government is just way too big too
intrusive and you have all this nonsense
going on and that is the reason i
believe that it's important that we
stick to our principles and not say well
a little bit of government here a little
bit the government there so for that
reason i left congress
much more adamant being opposed to big
government than the motivation i had to
go to congress
but uh you know i think the the whole
issue we talk about all that's going on
today and in foreign policy
and the bickering that goes on there's a
lot of that but the bickering that we
hear from my viewpoint has nothing to do
with the important issue and that has to
do with philosophy i don't believe
there's you know two parties i believe
there's only one party there and i think
bipartisanship is very bad i think
coalitions are okay but bipartisan
everything gets done by bipartisanship
the two parties have to agree with
everything that's been done for the 50
years they agree on funding and not even
examining these uh the security budgets
and the cia they don't it's always
bipartisan going to war
just let them go to war and we'll
finance them so it's always a
bipartisanship
but those that i frequently would get
the criticism that i'm overly rigid
and depends on what you're rigid about
depending on whether it's good or not
but i remember one time there was a a
one of the members of congress said um
well he was he was working to get a
credentials that he was against
corporate welfare so the export import
bank
appropriation was coming up so he wanted
to cut it five percent which meant
nothing
and we had to vote and it didn't pass no
way would would dare uh you know cut the
export import bank so uh
the next vote uh i had i wanted to
abolish the export in poor bank
so i supported the other gentleman's you
know amendment to cut it a little bit
but uh he wouldn't support mine so i
went up to him i said hey look i thought
you were against this stuff why don't
why aren't you voting with this he says
ron your trouble is you always just go
too far
but uh i think this is one of the
problems whether it's foreign policy or
domestic policy if you concede the
principle i think you can see it 100 of
it so if you say that we have to do such
and such uh type of welfare program or a
little bit of war a little bit of
intervention you can see this whole
principle that we're supposed to do it
so i do think although it's a goal that
won't be easily achieved you tell it
should take this principle and much has
been said today about
non-interventionism and i love that term
because non-interventionism tells you
what liberty is all about and it would
work go a long way for foreign policy as
well that we we should be if we believe
in the cause of liberty we should be
non-interventionist we should have a
government that does not intervene in
peaceful activity of all citizens just
mind let us mine our own business
and of course we should uh have a
government that if you believe in
markets you should have a
non-interventionist uh government that
doesn't try to regulate the economy and
just think of the thousands and
thousands of pages of regulations that
go on so it's too much intervention and
of course in foreign policy it's way
overblown to wait way too much
intervention
but you know there was a time when it
really bothered me when you started
reading uh you know revisionist history
because it challenged me quite frankly
when i started reading a little bit
about the lead up to world war ii and
that there was supposedly knowledge
possibly of what was going to happen at
pearl harbor i just didn't want to
believe that about my government and so
it took a long time to sort of soften my
stand on that but it's but the same way
i was drafted in 1962 during the cuban
crisis which was discussed here today
and then i was actually inducted in the
service in the early 1961 i was i was a
flight surgeon
at the airport
in san antonio the day before uh kennedy
was killed and i was in charge of
charge of the medical provision there
but there was no way at that time when
the assassination occurred that i i
would say you know
our government may well have been
involved i wouldn't want to hear any
part of that and of course uh you know
things like uh uh you know you know the
shooting up of the the liberty and one
thing and and what about 9 11 commission
but i came i've come to a conclusion to
see if you you think is a pretty good
assessment i think commissions are great
have commissions study all this because
when they're done
they really help you out if you're
looking for truth look at what they've
said and decide exactly the opposite is
the truth
[Applause]
we would have frequent briefings after 9
11 we had plenty and there are briefings
all the time to
tell us what's really going on well i
think i attended one and it was
disgusting
because i thought it was all just
propaganda it was spin it was trying to
get you to endorse a policy so i had a
general i ruled i just i just didn't go
for two reasons that you weren't going
to hear the truth and the second reason
is you could read it in the washington
post the next day if you wanted because
they'll put the information out but uh
no no
the propaganda
in washington uh usually was just a
distortion of what was going on
especially in in in foreign art in
foreign policy
but the um this whole idea of uh
defending and
supporting the constitution pretty
important we we so how many people have
said this oath you know in our
government and uh yet there's uh there's
not a whole lot of support in defense of
the constitution but i can simplify this
because the oath that is taken says
against all enemies foreign and domestic
well i've concluded that if you want to
do that that you really only have about
50 percent of that responsibility
because it's hard for me to figure out
who's going to invade us and destroy our
constitution that all comes from
internally and that's where the enemies
are here they're destroying our
constitution just look at the loss of
liberty since 9 11. it's incessant we do
it to ourselves so that's to me there
are a lot of enemies that are internal
and and that should be our job as much
as uh anything but overall how do we how
do we get to this point where we're so
out of whack of
what the intent was with our
constitution
and
i think one of the most important
issues that deals with it is the
educational system i think if you look
at the last uh 50 60 70 years matter of
fact uh it even started under eisenhower
especially with the department of health
education and welfare and the department
of education and now we have this
totally bizarre evil monstrosity of
cultural march and marxism which is
pushed by our universities i mean what
kind of a university system do we have
today where you can send the kid off
gets a fancy degree and studies
something in social studies he ends up
with a degree and seventy thousand
dollars worth of debt and he can't get a
job and he's supposed to be educated
it's a real mess and the longer the
federal government especially has been
involved the worse the educational
system uh has become i think it's an
indoctrination system i think it starts
in kindergarten and uh it's very simple
and this is why i like these the simple
answers to the problems there is no
authority in the constitution for the
federal government to be involved in
education and it should be taken out to
get rid of the department of education
and maybe something much better could
replace it
[Applause]
because of the system and what goes on
this is a great influence
you know the people i knew in congress
many of them are considered very decent
but very confused
and uh they didn't understand economics
you know at all
and they reflect you know what they've
been told and what they've been studying
how many universities still today
teach interventions economics uh you
know keynesianism and who's most popular
book in in all the universes set paul
samuelson you know it had nothing to do
with sound money and free markets and
this sort of thing so it and and that's
why
the majority of the people that come to
washington are going to do what they do
and they and they feel good about it and
once they accept this notion that
there's something wrong with an overly
rigid constitution and they have this
excuse that you should be ready to adapt
the constitution and then they get
indoctrinated in our in our educational
system then we end up with this mess
that that we have and uh yes the details
are important
and you know i spent a lot of time
leading up to the iraq war dealing with
trying to point out all the reasons we
shouldn't do it i think one time i had
one talk i listened 34 reasons why we
shouldn't do it and that's important to
do that but overall it's really the
principle of the thing should we be
involved and the founders sort of gave
us a hint stay out of entangling
alliances we don't need this
international we need more emphasis on
personal liberty personal responsibility
and not internationalism you know if
education there was no prohibition about
the states or local communities be
involved with education i went through
public school it was only the local
community and then the communities got
bigger then the state took over and then
it was the federal government took over
and now it's the united nations and
everybody else that wants to get get in
on the act and and that that is what's
wrong so i think that if you take uh if
you take a firm principle and say they
shouldn't be involved
then things would be much better now if
you look at all our foreign policy
you say well how do they how do they do
this where do they get all the money
well they had to have a a neat little
system to finance this this and welfare
the welfare warfare state is very very
real and it's deadly and uh of course if
you go back uh to a few years uh prior
to world war one if you go back to 1913
were already setting the stage they were
setting the stage in one year they said
that
your income is not your income it all
belongs to the government and will allow
you to keep it if you do what we tell
you
and uh if if if you don't do what we
tell you
you will have to prove you're you're
going to be considered guilty until you
prove yourself innocent so we started
off small and we had the income tax and
of course along with that that we had
the viciousness of another instrument
that i think that we
should be concerned about and that and
and that is another enemy of liberty and
that is
central banking you cannot solve these
problems unless you deal with the
monetary issue and the best way to deal
with that is the same way you deal with
the department of education you need to
get rid of the federal reserve system
[Applause]
and of course
and of course the uh
the the uh uh all the agencies and the
uh
internal revenue the the whole works we
we uh we just don't need that
you know but the um the conditions that
really excite people
though uh we'll we'll be uh we we have
to be
a international leader we have to be the
leader of the community we have to be a
world leader americans like it everybody
likes it i like the idea i think we
should be a world leader
and but their idea the opposition their
idea of a world leader is we own it that
we have an empire and we support it and
you do it with a gun
i have another idea about uh
supporting world leadership is why
couldn't we have a country based on
personal liberty not intervention in our
lives non-interventional economy
non-intervention and other people's
affairs have sound money and free
markets and set a standard and be
the real leader of the world not because
we're telling them what to do but
because maybe they would like to emulate
what we're doing because of our success
that is my idea of being a world leader
[Applause]
the
chances of that happening of course
aren't all that good right now
but uh you know like so many things
there's a uh a good uh a good part and a
bad part then then and right now it's
real easy to talk about all the bad
things because this last hundred years
has not been kind to liberty and
although there's great prosperity
because if you own stock you should feel
real good
but
for some reason owning stocks right now
from my viewpoint is superficial and it
doesn't reveal what's really going on in
this country and if you look and see
what's happening in this country and
who's doing it and and who is the enemy
you have some sorting out to do right
now i am convinced at least half of our
population
you know are in trouble financially and
even the economic statistics this week
so you know revealed this they have 95
million people that are out of the
workforce so what does that do they're
out of the workforce so there are less
people considered to be workers and
unemployment rates down to 4.3 so
does that make everybody feel good well
wall street feels good so it's it's
gimmickry and of course uh when they ran
into trouble in oano nine what did they
have they have a real financial crisis
well let's go to the congress and see
what they can do because it's their
responsibility well they you know they'd
spend a billion here no a trillion here
and a trillion there
saying they're going to solve that
problem but it was all fluff it it it
didn't do any good we know that that
went debt actually doubled uh since that
time it went from 10 to 20 trillion
dollars but
while the congress is tinkering around
with a trillion dollars here and there
the fed is tinkering with 15 or 17
trillion dollars and passing it out to
make the economy great you know we uh
you know we there's a 500 percent
increase in the balance sheet of the
federal reserve and
quite frankly it's it's not going to
last and uh it will just distort things
it will
the the enemy that the philosophic
enemies will have created this condition
where there is a male distribution of
wealth and so when the liberals complain
about that they're right that
why is this group over here more
billionaires than ever before now we're
going to have a trillionaire and you
have 50 of the people really are under
underemployed and uh it's a consequence
though of the government it's a
consequence of the federal reserve it's
a consequence of what happens when you
destroy a a currency but right now we're
able to do this uh you know through
through the federal reserve system the
um
the people uh uh you know uh
they they accept this whole notion that
it's all right to pretend that what you
need is inflation money supply and money
is wealth and that will solve the
problem which obviously isn't true the
report this past week tells us a little
bit about what's really going on new
york city uh has tremendous number of
people who are homeless the story
yesterday was on la
la had a tremendous increase in people
you know living on the street and they
went and somebody did an interview and
they talked to some of the uh people who
were homeless and it wasn't like they
weren't working some were working and
trying to pay the bills and they were
saying uh well
my cost of living is too high and and i
and i can't do this and i can't afford
the rent
and uh because it's too high cost of
living going up rent's going up i work
and it's not enough and what does our
federal reserve say well we do have a
problem here and we want to energize the
economy and how we energize the economy
is we need to take the price inflation
rate up to two percent and we need more
inflation and cause prices that go up
and high rising prices to them is a sign
that there's prosperity it didn't help
zimbabwe and didn't help venezuela you
know prices soar but they this is the
ridiculousness
of the system that we have but uh right
now there's a bit of euphoria and people
are feeling great and and we have uh
been able to capture this by uh
you know being in a position of of uh
printing and creating the reserve
currency of the world and that of course
uh really came out and some speakers
alluded to the the strength of the
united states after world war ii and it
has been very strong and very trusting
we have the military we have the wealth
and uh they trust us uh to a degree but
less all the time and uh and but we've
been able to do this and deficits can be
handled to the point but it's all an
illusion and i think it all goes back to
this idea that we as americans should
really question uh who the enemies are
what are the odds right now
of some country coming in here and
invading and taking over maybe after the
chaos who knows what's going to happen
but even you know today we're in the
persian gulf i guess you realize we're
over there we have a few vessels over
there and planes and bombs and drones
and we have uh
we're very much involved in making sure
that nobody uh
drags up a lot of sand and makes a new
island in the south sea south china sea
well you know what would they what would
we do what would the texans do if they
did that in the gulf of mexico uh what
if they did the chesapeake bay and
nobody wants to re on our in our country
they generally don't want to look and
put the same calculation on ourselves as
on on others and they too readily accept
this idea that we are an exceptional
nation and that
we we have goodness to spread and all
you have to do is look at where all that
goodness is and ask whether or not the
military industrial complex is enjoying
this goodness because their part they're
part of the real problem and uh so this
is um this is sort of uh you know
inherent in the system and until we look
at this in a from an intellectual
viewpoint and decide you know what what
should our country be all about should
we be defending and protecting liberty
or should be we pretend that we know how
to run people's lives they said what are
you going to do to let the people die in
the streets they won't have any medical
scare and we know that's all a fraud
more people are suffering from lack of
medical care now since the government's
been involved it's a disaster what's
going on what's happening and there's no
way they can afford it
once again how could we solve that
problem get the government out of
believing and the american people
believing that it's the federal
government's responsibility to
distribute medical care they shouldn't
be doing it they don't have a right to
do it
[Applause]
the one thing that has motivated many to
support
support our foreign policy
is is you know this whole idea that uh
there there's a danger of terrorism well
there is there is a danger of terrorism
but if you've seen the statistics uh
comparatively speaking they're rather
minor you know i think you have a
hundred times greater chance of getting
hit by lightning than by terrorists uh
and and if you looked at uh uh city
crime and inner city crime and the
results of the drug war how many people
die uh in i think it's something like 88
in a day and yet you're talking a dozen
or two or three uh from from terrorism
but you've got to build the fear the
fear of an economic collapse and that's
why the fed has to do this and why
congress has to spend more money the
same way on the militarism they're
they're dangerous they're coming they're
going to get us and we have to go and
stop them over there
and uh you know the other biggest hoax
on this uh foreign policy and this uh
intrigue about uh defending the
constitution a lot of people uh you know
how often do you hear on tv now on why
we have to be over there and why we had
to go into iraq the justification was to
go into iraq to defend our constitution
and defend our freedoms how ridiculous
can it get
you know to go in
you're defying the constitution it was
an undeclared war and we've made
ourselves so much less free and people
buy into this stuff
but uh fortunately we still have
vehicles we have the future of freedom
foundation and the few others it's going
to get this message out because it can
be changed
[Applause]
and that's where i i tend to be uh a lot
more optimistic than you might believe
because uh
the um
the the chances are going to be numerous
because the one thing for certain
um is that the system that we have
endless spending
endless debt endless inflation of the
money supply endless intervention
uh it's going to end it's going to end
and in the big problem though that we
have to face is how is it going to end
is it going to be so chaotic that there
be decades of real chaos where we can't
survive and make it difficult or will it
be an opportunity and i think this it
will be an opportunity because i think
today we have more more groups
giving out information like the future
of pure freedom foundation and others
and there's a lot of young people
studying austrian economics there's a
lot of people who do care and understand
what civil liberties all about even
though the campuses are a mess i still
go to the campuses still can get some
people out and there's a lot of people
there that are on the wrong right track
and the one thing that encourages me is
i never look and say well i need to go
out there
one of my biggest rallies i had in
presidential campaign was at berkeley
believe it or not i mean it was huge
but if i went there i thought well i got
to get 51 of the people at berkeley
agreeing with this you know it would be
just too too devastating and uh but but
there's always some there and in large
numbers and they're enthusiastic and a
young person if they get the right
information they realize that they have
a lot at stake
and i i think it's uh very encouraging
on on what's happening and that uh
there's there's reason to believe that
some some good can come of this i keep
thinking of this in the big picture and
the big picture for me is what's
happened you know for uh literally
hundreds if not thousands of years about
the human race uh developing not much
really happened uh you know in in the
sense of uh of technical developments up
to about 300 years ago you think what
was before that it was there was a lot
of fancy things but really the fantastic
technology and even today technology is
improving the living condition
and yet every time we improve the living
condition it seems like we use the
technology not only for some people's
uh
living condition and improving but it's
also used to fight wars and kill people
know more efficiently drop bigger bombs
and uh and and you know get more more
involved but uh
the uh
the the people who understand this
realize that uh there there could be a
different way why why is it that uh
you know if we made this great change in
the human race by technology it is and
just in the last hundred years really
there's been fantastic technological
advances but what about uh what about
the human race advancing otherwise why
can't we advance on how we get along
together
you know that would be a real real real
chore wouldn't it but you know i still
come down on the side that i think most
people are decent
but not in washington
washington is a different story
because well anyway why they go there is
a different story but but no i keep
thinking
uh my wife and i are raising kids we
lived in several states and five six
different houses and we had
neighborhoods i can't remember once
where i worried about my neighbor
my neighbors were always good neighbors
sometimes we didn't talk much but we
never had to worry about them and
sometimes they would help help each
other so i think people are i think
there's more goodness in people than we
give them credit for i think the problem
is is that
the people who like
authoritarianism to tell people what to
do they know it's illegal for
an individual to go into your house and
take what they want fortunately that
moral standard still exists you can't
personally take from people and hurt
people
it happens but basically most people
recognize you can't do it but it's not
illegal for the government to do it this
is why
it's so important if there are some good
rules for us to have a good community in
getting along with people
we as a country and as a as a people
what we have to do is hold the feet to
the fire of government where those
individuals that go to government are
not allowed to use force or violence to
try to have their way in any way
whatsoever
that i think would make a difference
[Applause]
and uh there is only one rule you have
to think about and it's not a complex
rule i mean we have what what do what
are the keynesian interventionists and
people who want to
manage these interventions formed by boy
you have to have a lot of rules you know
and figure out well you do it on this
side and
on this hand on this hand you do this
write more regulations and all but
there's only one rule that you need and
that is the rule that we apply to
ourselves we don't have a right to hurt
people we don't have a right to steal
from people and those are ancient
traditions
some thousands of years old plain and
simple don't lie cheat steal or kill and
yet we have governments involved
probably in killing you know who knows
we certainly have our government
involved in killing uh you know with
these undeclared illegal immoral wars uh
you know like million iraqis have died
since we went in there to save that
country
it's it's just utterly tragic uh what
what goes on uh
so how do how do you do that i think the
founders tried to solve that problem
they tried to give us what they called a
republic keep the cut
the government very small advise us to
stay out of entangling alliances allow a
national defense uh but it didn't work
uh so how do you
how do you do it if it's natural for
people who love authoritarianism to go
where they can use their
authoritarianism
and it hasn't worked so what is the
other option i think the other option is
we need to change our idea of what the
nature of government is
and that is don't permit a government
that can do these things and if we could
just allow that to happen when it
happens people do so much better you
know it's it's not like they don't it's
not like if tomorrow all government is
wiped out in a minute with medical care
believe me you know there would be some
adjustments pretty fast
fees would come down a whole lot let me
tell you and the insurance company
wouldn't be breaking off the top and the
drug companies wouldn't be abusing the
system the management companies that are
involved all that expense that we've
experienced for the last not only on
obamacare because the republicans have
introduced a lot of that too it's
government intervention that caused all
these prices to go up so if you
eliminated all these middlemen believe
me it would uh it would it would be so
much better today even today under these
conditions uh there are people who stake
out totally private hospital and they
just take cash and that's it and they're
out of the system and it actually worked
so when you we have difficult situations
like this and we're trying to find out
who the real enemies are what we have to
do
is make sure there's always a loophole
for everybody to opt out that was
probably the most onerous thing about
obamacare that you couldn't get out you
had to be pushed into that thing but you
ought to always be able to opt out the
educational system in a way has an
opt-out in it we can we can get out of
it uh even though it's not universally
available but uh they did try in the 80s
to make sure that you couldn't
homeschool your kids and there was a
tack on homeschooling and private school
schooling and they want to regulate
private school still but if you can get
if you can get out of the system
and if they eliminate any option to get
out whether it's medical care or
education that is very very bad and
we're at that point where opting out is
is more difficult so
i think this is one thing we could do
but i i believe that this is a
non-viable system that we have and
the enemies are more philosophic than
they are just individuals who are mis
misled i think there's a philosophy
behind this i think cultural marxism
isn't accidental of people who was
gently misled they have goals to cause
chaos chaos cultural chaos and for for a
strategy to destroy uh you know the
culture that we have and uh sometimes we
come up with these uh uh questions about
how do you protect civil liberties and
predict everybody's religious liberties
and sexual liberties inside you know
public institutions well the best way is
get rid of the public institution
and then and then if it's a private
institution if it's a religious
institution or a private institution you
get to write your own rules oh well that
introduces uh
some some other other problems that
means that you might have to make
choices on who can come and who can go
well you know in freedom actually you
are allowed to make your own choices and
uh one other word that they've destroyed
is to be discriminatory we're all
discriminatory everything we do you made
a choice to come here i made a choice to
stay away from chantilly
now we always make these we always make
these choices it's constant but they
want to make you believe that you're not
allowed to pick and choose we we do we
pick our we pick our
people who come into our house we pick
schools and all these things so it's
constantly making choices but they don't
want to somebody else is supposed to
make make those decisions for us and uh
that uh that is what's so so hard for
people to understand and understand is
uh in in civil liberties if people use
their liberties we might not like how
can we tolerate them because uh we don't
agree with them on this
if they do the one thing and don't use
force you know and we if we just sort of
say you mind your own business do what
you want call yourselves whatever you
want but you cannot take your standards
and push them and force them on somebody
else
society would work but our the people
who who are in opposition to us they're
not looking for peace and tranquility
they're looking for chaos and right now
uh they're they're on the verge of
getting their chaos and uh and but we
have to look always look for uh
you know a um a solution and an
opportunity the one other issue i want
to touch on before i close and that is
um the the privacy issue you know
because we do want to be safe and we do
want to be secure and there's a room for
a little bit of surveillance
but it should be strict it should be
strict and the founders thought about
this this mass surveillance of all
americans this is atrocious but if you
had had the whole system of having
search warrants and all and uh there are
so many solutions one there's one agency
i don't know whether anybody here has
ever been annoyed by tsa anybody in this
room been annoyed by tsa i'd like to get
rid of the tsa and i voted against the
tsa it should be private it should be
the private people dealing with their
customers and
and that means there's technology now
where they can scan people so so fast
and that's one part of technology that
wouldn't destroy productive jobs because
the tsa agents would have to go get a
productive job and we would have better
security than ever before so see but
privacy is very very important and that
is a principle of of liberty but
the the the solution is understanding
where
the importance of our life liberty and
and and our property and that it's a
natural right and it's come to us in a
natural race in a beneficial way and if
we have enough people and believe me it
doesn't need 51 percent it needs 10
at the most to change people's attitudes
and that's why you're here and that and
that's why you're part of that group and
that's why you can have a lot of
influence and that's why i'm optimistic
i want to thank you very much today
[Applause]
we have a 25 minute break and we got
appetizers out in the hallway
you're watching